I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。
Good morning. Good morning. Good afternoon. Good evening. You're very peppy for some reason. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. morning. Good afternoon. Good evening. You're very peppy for such a serious subject. I am really excited about this episode. Everyone it's murder.
早上好。早上好。下午好。晚上好。不知怎么的，你今天真有精神。对不起。对不起。上午好。下午好。晚上好。对于这么严肃的话题，你可真有活力。我对这一集真的超级兴奋。大家，这是一起谋杀案。
Oh, dun dun dun. Season six, episode ten, written by Daniel Chun and directed by Greg Daniels. And we have a special treat this week for you for our summary. So, 10, written by Daniel Chun and directed by Greg Daniels. And we have a special treat this week for you for our summary. We do. Okay, so you guys, you know I have a big Southern family. We're spread out between Louisiana and Texas.
哦，咚咚咚。第六季第十集，丹尼尔·陈编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。这周我们的剧情梗概有一个特别惊喜送给大家。所以，第十集由丹尼尔·陈编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。这周我们的剧情梗概有一个特别惊喜送给大家。我们确实有。好的，大家知道我有一个庞大的南方家族。我们的亲戚分布在路易斯安那州和德克萨斯州。
And I know it's not Savannah, Georgia, but my sister, Billy Jo, has a great Southern accent. And I asked her to read our summary today. And she did. Here it is. I do declare there's been a mudda. Michael attempts to distract his employees with a mudda mystery party after everyone hears rumors that the company might be going bankrupt. Jim wants everyone to keep walking and is frustrated by Michael's game. Meanwhile, Andy attempts
我知道这不属于佐治亚州萨凡纳，但我姐姐比利·乔有着一口好听的南方口音。我请她今天来读我们的梗概。她照做了。听好了。我敢说出大事了，死人了。在听到公司可能要破产的传闻后，迈克尔试图通过一场谋杀之谜派对来分散员工的注意力。吉姆希望大家继续工作，对迈克尔的游戏感到沮丧。与此同时，安迪试图
to ask Erin out on a date. Angela, she nailed it. She nailed it. Jenna, I was so tickled by this. I knew I wanted someone in my family because this episode partly takes place in Savannah, Georgia. Yes. So I knew I would want someone from my Southern family to give the summary a go. And thank you, Billy. Thank you, Billy, for giving it a shot. Well, she can do the summary anytime, Ange. Billy Jo, did you hear that? Right now she's like, no, no, no, no, no.
约艾琳出去约会。安吉拉，她太拿捏了。她拿捏得死死的。珍娜，我被逗得太开心了。我知道我想找我家族里的人来读，因为这一集的部分场景发生在佐治亚州萨凡纳。是的。所以我想找一个南方家族的人来试读这个梗概。谢谢你，比利。谢谢你，比利，愿意尝试一下。好吧，安琪，她随时都可以来读梗概。比利·乔，你听到了吗？现在她大概在想，不，不，不，不，不。
Somewhere she's yelling, no, no, no. Well let's get into fast facts. Fast fact number one is all about our new writer for this episode, Daniel Chun. We know him as Danny. He started on the writing staff for season six. He was a supervising producer and this was his first script. Danny had previously written on The Simpsons for six years. I was able to get back in touch with him, which was so fun. And he told me that he knew a lot of the office writers socially
她一定在某个地方大喊，不，不，不。好吧，让我们进入快速事实环节。快速事实一讲的是我们这集的新编剧丹尼尔·陈。我们叫他丹尼。他从第六季开始加入编剧团队。他曾担任监制，这是他写的第一份剧本。丹尼以前曾为《辛普森一家》写过六年剧本。我能联系上他，这太有趣了。他告诉我，他通过喜剧写作圈子在社交上认识了许多《办公室》的编剧。
just through the comedy writing community. He knew BJ for a long time. He said that he loved being at the Simpsons, but he kind of felt like 80% of working on that show was just punching up jokes, unless you were the show runner. So he didn't get to do a lot of long form writing there, I guess. He said he was really hungry for a different challenge. BJ had always been a big supporter of his writing and he showed Mindy and Paul some stuff that Danny had written just for fun on MySpace. Remember MySpace? No way!
他和BJ认识很久了。他说他很喜欢在《辛普森一家》工作，但他觉得在这部剧里80%的工作都只是润色笑话，除非你是剧集运作人。所以我想他在那里没有机会做太多长篇写作。他说他真的很渴望不同的挑战。BJ一直非常支持他的写作，他把丹尼在MySpace上随手写的一些东西拿给敏迪和保罗看。还记得MySpace吗？不会吧！
Oh my God, yeah! He said, that gives you a sense of how long ago this was. But the stuff he had written on MySpace got him a meeting. They brought him in and that's how he got hired to be one of our writers for season six. See guys, you never know. You never know. Yeah, all that stuff that you're writing, if it's a blog, if it's a vlog, I don't even know. All the logs. You're creating it. All the logs out there.
哦天哪，对啊！他说，这能让你感觉到那是多久以前的事了。但他在MySpace上写的东西帮他争取到了一次会面机会。他们把他请了过来，这就是他被雇佣成为我们第六季编剧之一的经过。听着，伙计们，你永远不知道。你永远不知道。是的，你写的所有那些东西，不管是博客，还是视频博客，我甚至不知道。所有的日志。你都在创作。所有的日志都在那里。
All of them. Someone could see it. Yes. So, fast fact number two, I was able to talk to Danny a little bit about the inspiration for this episode of Murder. What was it? He said this was a card on the wall. What did the card say?
全都在。总有人能看到。是的。那么，快速事实二，我得以和丹尼聊了聊关于这一集《谋杀案》灵感的一些事情。灵感是什么？他说墙上曾有一张卡片。卡片上写了什么？
The card said, Michael makes everyone play a murder mystery game. It was one of the pitches they had come up with over the summer. He also remembered a card that never got made. It was this. They go on a ski trip and someone makes a huge stain on the wall. Ew! I know! But he was pointing out, like, this is how simple a card could be. But they picked
卡片上写着，迈克尔让每个人都玩谋杀之谜游戏。这是他们在夏天想出的众多点子之一。他还记得有一张从未被采用的卡片。内容是这样的：他们去滑雪旅行，有人在墙上留下了一个巨大的污渍。咦！我知道！但他的意思是，一张卡片可以很简单。但他们挑中了
this one, and then they had to figure out how, why, what happens, how is this a whole episode? So on Mom Detectives a card could be two ladies on a train with a succulent. Yes and that has to be a whole episode. That's an episode. Yeah. Now you have to turn that into something. Yeah. Danny said they also for season six had all of these mini-arcs that they were going to add to the season. Those are little stories that take place over several episodes. And one of those ideas was that Dunder Mifflin was going to go bankrupt. And another one was that Jim would get this co-manager position. That's already happened. But this episode of the Murder Mystery Game, they thought it tied in really well with that mini arc
这个，然后他们不得不弄清楚如何、为什么、发生了什么，这怎么能构成完整的一集呢？所以对《妈妈侦探》来说，一张卡片可能就是两个带有多肉植物的女士在火车上。没错，那必须是一整集。那就是一集。对。现在你得把它变成点什么。对。丹尼说他们为第六季准备了所有这些他们打算加入剧中的微型故事线。那些是在好几集中展开的小故事。其中一个构想是邓德米夫林将要破产。另一个构想是吉姆将获得这个联席经理职位。这已经发生了。但这一集的谋杀之谜游戏，他们觉得与邓德米夫林倒闭这条微型故事线完美契合。
of Dundermifflin going out of business. Oh, for sure. So there is a DVD commentary for this episode. Oh, so it features Ellie Kemper, Danny Chun and Greg Daniels. And they talked a little bit about this episode setting up three major arcs. Like exactly what you're saying, the crumbling of Dundra Mifflin, the sale to Saber, and Andy and Aaron. Yes, the Andy and Aaron. You're right. That's another one. Danny also told me that the writers played one of these murder mystery games for research in the writer's room. He said they noticed that in all of the games, the people had silly pun names,
哦，确实如此。所以这一集是有DVD评论音轨的。哦，里面有艾莉·坎珀、丹尼·陈和格雷格·丹尼尔斯。他们稍微聊了聊这一集为三个主要故事线做了铺垫。就像你说的，邓德米夫林的崩溃、被萨伯收购，以及安迪和艾琳。没错，安迪和艾琳。你说的对。那是另一个。丹尼还告诉我，编剧们在编剧室里为了做研究，曾玩过一次这种谋杀之谜游戏。他说他们注意到在所有这些游戏中，人们都有一些滑稽的双关名字，
so they knew they were gonna have to do that. There was a CD with a narrator that would help you along. He said in the game they played, his character was a Frenchman, and so he was stumbling through a French accent while they were playing, and that kind of gave them the idea that they should have a game where everybody has to have accents.
所以他们知道他们也得这么做。有一张带有旁白的光盘可以引导你进行游戏。他说在他们玩的游戏中，他的角色是个法国人，所以在玩的时候他一直在模仿生硬的法国口音，这大概给了他们灵感，让他们觉得应该做一款所有人都要带口音的游戏。
He also said that they originally thought that this game could be Murder in Little Italy, but they were afraid that would feel too much like the Mafia episode, and so that's when they pitched the game be set in Savannah. Well, Danny said mainly he just remembered feeling like the game was not that much fun. It involved a lot of acting. And so he thought about that. And he thought that's why people like Andy and Michael would like the game. I just really like how much playing this game in the writer's room informed them.
他还说他们最初以为这个游戏可以叫《小意大利谋杀案》，但他们担心那会太像黑手党那一集了，所以后来他们才把游戏背景定在萨凡纳。好吧，丹尼说主要原因是他只记得当时觉得这个游戏没那么好玩。里面包含了很多表演。所以他想到了这一点。他觉得这就是为什么像安迪和迈克尔这样的人会喜欢这个游戏。我真的很喜欢在编剧室里玩这个游戏的过程给他们带来的启发。
You know? Yeah. Because Danny was like, I don't like playing this game. I don't like doing an accent and it's too much acting. I feel like he now could write very well for Angela. And Stanley. Yeah. But he's like, somebody would like this.
你知道吗？是的。因为丹尼当时说，我不喜欢玩这个游戏。我不喜欢模仿口音，而且演的成分太多了。我觉得他现在很适合为安吉拉写剧本。还有斯坦利。是的。但他觉得，总会有人喜欢这个的。
I guess Andy and Michael. I thought this was an amazing episode. So Danny, my gosh, your first one out of the gate. Home run. I really liked it too. All right, fast fact number three, Angela, is a fan question from Megan H. in Edmonton, Alberta, Canada, who would like to know if either of us
我猜安迪和迈克尔会喜欢。我觉得这一集太棒了。所以丹尼，天哪，你开局的第一部作品。本垒打。我也真的很喜欢。好吧，快速事实三，安吉拉，是来自加拿大艾伯塔省埃德蒙顿的梅根·H.提出的粉丝问题，她想知道我们两个中的任何一个
have ever done a murder mystery event, like in the show. Great question. I actually have a story. Jenna, do you have one? I do too. Okay. You go first. Oh, okay. I was once invited to a dinner party where they said there will be dinner and then we will be playing a game as a group. Did they say what the game was? No. Oh. And when I got there at dinner, the host explained the game while we ate our meal. Guess who the hosts were? Who? Oscar Nunez.
是否曾参加过像剧里那样的谋杀之谜活动。好问题。我其实有个故事。珍娜，你有一个吗？我也有。好吧。你先说。哦，好吧。我曾经被邀请去参加一个晚宴，他们说会有晚餐，然后我们作为集体一起玩个游戏。他们说是什么游戏了吗？没有。哦。当我到达晚宴现场时，主人在我们用餐时解释了这个游戏。你猜主人是谁？谁？奥斯卡·努涅斯。
What? Yes, and his wife Ursula. Oscar hosted you for a murder mystery game night? Yes. Was this before this episode or after? Before this episode. Oh my gosh. So the game was called Mafia. Oh yeah. This is really a popular game. This was like all the
什么？是的，还有他的妻子乌苏拉。奥斯卡招待你玩谋杀之谜游戏之夜？是的。这是在这一集之前还是之后？在这一集之前。哦天哪。所以这个游戏叫黑手党。哦对。这真的是一个很受欢迎的游戏。这在洛杉矶
rage in Los Angeles for a very long time. I don't know if this went over the whole country, but people were crazy about this game. Crazy about it. And they had the rules. I was actually texting with Ursula yesterday. I was like, Ursula, what did you guys call it? Because in my memory, they called it killer. And she goes, no, Angela, it was called mafia. Yes. And so there were about 10 of us at the dinner party. And there's a few different ways you can play this.
风靡了很长一段时间。我不知道这是否风靡了整个国家，但人们对这个游戏疯狂着迷。疯狂着迷。他们有规则。我昨天还跟乌苏拉发短信来着。我说，乌苏拉，你们当时管这叫什么？因为在我的记忆里，他们叫它杀手。她说，不，安吉拉，它叫黑手党。是的。所以晚宴上大概有10个人左右。有几种不同的玩法。
But the way we played it was there was one mafia, one killer, a detective, a doctor, and a narrator. And then you had the civilians. Okay. And the narrator kind of moves it along. The narrator's who knows who's who, right? Oh, okay. Because that seems like not as much fun of a part.
但我们的玩法是有一个黑手党，一个杀手，一个侦探，一个医生和一个旁白。然后还有平民。好的。旁白负责推进游戏。旁白是知道谁是谁的人，对吧？哦，好吧。因为听起来那个角色没那么好玩。
It actually is. I've been the narrator before and it's kind of fun. Oh, okay. Go ahead. I never played Mafia, which I kind of can't believe because I'm a sucker for these games. I want us to do this. Oh my gosh, Earwolf Company Party. We play Mafia.
其实挺好玩的。我以前当过旁白，还挺有趣的。哦，好吧。你接着说。我从来没玩过黑手党，我简直有点不敢相信，因为我对这类游戏毫无抵抗力。我想让我们玩这个。天哪，耳狼公司派对。我们来玩黑手党。
Have you guys played it? Sam, Cassie, have you played Mafia? No, I haven't, but I do remember the absolute stranglehold that it had over everybody for a while. Oh yeah. Wurdle or Animal Crossing at that time. Yes. Everybody was in it.
你们玩过吗？萨姆，卡西，你们玩过黑手党吗？没有，我没玩过，但我确实记得它曾经对所有人形成的绝对统治地位。哦，对。就像那时的《Wordle》或《动物森友会》。是的。所有人都沉迷其中。
Everyone was playing it. So in Mafia, the game is divided into two phases, day and night. During the night, everyone closes their eyes, and the narrator awakens each role. So the narrator starts with the Mafia person, lets them know who it is, because in each round, it's someone new, right?
每个人都在玩。所以在黑手党里，游戏分为两个阶段，白天和黑夜。在夜晚，所有人闭上眼睛，旁白唤醒各个角色。所以旁白从黑手党人员开始，让他们知道是谁，因为每一轮都是新的人，对吧？
And as the Mafia person, the way you kill someone is you wink at them. So you have to be real sneaky. At least that's how we played it. And then the doctor can choose to save someone or not. And the civilians have to try to figure out because every time they awaken, someone is dead. Oh. Right?
作为黑手党人员，你杀人的方式是向他们眨眼。所以你必须非常鬼祟。至少我们的玩法是这样的。然后医生可以选择救或者不救某个人。平民必须设法弄清楚，因为每次他们醒来时，都有人死了。哦。对吧？
Because the mafia person kills someone each time. So the civilians begin questioning each other and there's a detective role. But I imagine though also the mafia person is, and the doctor, they're pretending, everyone's pretending to be a civilian. Yes. Right. Yes. And it's so much fun.
因为黑手党人员每次都会杀死一个人。所以平民开始互相盘问，还有一个侦探的角色。但我猜同时黑手党人员和医生，他们在假装，所有人都假装自己是平民。是的。对吧？是的。而且超级好玩。
In one time I was the mafia person and no one figured me out. But what does that say? It says you were very good at pretending to be a civilian. You're diabolical. It was really, really fun. But yes, I played a version of this murder mystery with Oscar in real life. Wow, before this episode. Before this episode.
有一次我是黑手党人员，没有人发现我。但那说明了什么？说明你非常擅长假装成平民。你太阴险了。真的非常非常有趣。不过是的，我在现实生活中和奥斯卡一起玩过这个谋杀之谜的版本。哇，在这一集之前。在这一集之前。
That's very cool. I know, is that crazy? I did not have to wear a funny hat or have an accent, I should say. I guess you could have chosen to. Well, it is very funny that you say that, Angela, because I did a mini deep dive on the murder mystery game genre, and they believe that it began in the first half of the 19th century with a party game called Wink Murder. Oh!
太酷了。我知道，是不是很疯狂？我应该说，我当时不需要戴滑稽的帽子或说奇怪的口音。我想你也可以选择戴。嗯，你这么说真好笑，安吉拉，因为我对谋杀之谜游戏流派做了一次微型深度研究，他们认为它起源于19世纪上半叶的一款名为“眨眼谋杀”的派对游戏。哦！
Yeah, one player is secretly selected as a murderer and they kill other players by winking at them. That's what we did! If you get killed, you have to count to five before you die. Yes! Right, is this it? Yes, because you can't just give it away, so you have to like make a moment of it.
是的，一名玩家被秘密选为杀手，他们通过向其他玩家眨眼来杀死对方。这就是我们玩的！如果你被杀了，你必须在死前数到五。是的！对，就是这个吗？是的，因为你不能直接泄露，所以你得制造点戏剧效果。
This is so weird. Is mafia just based on wink murder? So far it's sounding like it. I will say this. If you play mafia with your friends and you're the murderer and you're not good at winking. Oh no. I never thought of that. Like me.
这也太奇怪了。黑手党难道只是基于眨眼谋杀吗？目前听起来是这样的。我得这么说。如果你和朋友玩黑手党，你是杀手，而你又不擅长眨眼。哦不。我从没想过这一点。就像我一样。
I think I'm good with one eye. You just winked at me great with both eyes. Did I really? Yeah, you did fine. Oh. Well, I'm sorry. No, see, I'm right. I've watched you closer this time.
我觉得我用一只眼睛眨得挺好。你刚刚用两双眼睛向我完美地眨了眨。我真的吗？对，你做得很好。哦。好吧，我很抱歉。不，你看，我是对的。这次我仔细观察你了。
The right eye. You do regular wink with this eye, and then the other eye, you go. I know. So I can wink in normal speed with one eye, but the other one is like, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk. I can see you concentrating on it. To try to wink. Yeah. So you got to figure out what's your good eye.
右眼。你用这只眼睛正常眨眼，然后另一只眼，你就像这样。我知道。所以我可以用一只眼以正常速度眨眼，但另一只眼就像是，砰，砰，砰，砰。我能看出你在集中精力。努力去眨眼。所以你得找出哪只是你的好眼。
Well, I have never played Mafia. I have never played a murder mystery game. Yeah, what's your story? But I was an actor. What? In Murder Mystery Dinner Theater. Come on! Yep.
好吧，我从来没玩过黑手党。我也从来没玩过谋杀之谜游戏。是的，你的故事是什么？但我以前是个演员。什么？在谋杀之谜晚宴剧场里。别逗了！对。
Is there any footage of that? Can I see any of that? I have a photo of myself in my crushed velvet gown. I played several parts in several different shows. This was my very first paid live theater acting gig. I did it in St. Louis, Missouri at the Lemp Mansion. A bunch of people would come in. Wait, was it like an old mansion?
有那段录像吗？我能看一眼吗？我有一张穿着碎天鹅绒礼服的照片。我在好几部不同的戏里演过好几个角色。这是我第一份带薪的现场戏剧表演工作。我是在密苏里州圣路易斯的兰普大厦做的。很多人会来。等等，那是栋老宅子吗？
Like a haunted sort of cool like old mansion? Yeah, and I even had a ghost encounter there. Come on. While I was working there, I did. I did, I saw the Lavender Lady. Come on. I did. What is the Lavender Lady?
就像那种闹鬼的、很酷的老宅子？是的，我甚至在那里遇到过幽灵。别开玩笑了。我工作的时候确实遇到过。真的，我看到了薰衣草夫人。别闹了。真的。谁是薰衣草夫人？
I don't know. I didn't know who the Lavender Lady? I don't know. I didn't know who the Lavender Lady was, but I was in what was one of the rooms of the house that they designated for the actors to change in. And no one was supposed to come in there because that was our changing room. And I heard the door open behind me. And I looked up in the mirror in front of me and behind me by the door, saw a woman and I said I'm sorry you can't be in here and when I turned around there was nothing there. So I was fired up. I went to the owner of the place and I said listen if you're gonna give us a place to change our
我不知道。我当时不知道谁是薰衣草夫人？我不知道。我当时不知道谁是薰衣草夫人，当时我在屋里的一个房间里，那是他们指定给演员换衣服的房间。而且任何人都不准进来，因为那是我们的更衣室。我听到身后门开了。我抬头看着面前的镜子，看到门边的身后站着一个女人，我说，对不起，你不能待在这里，当我转过身时，什么都没有。所以我当时火冒三丈。我找到那里的老板说，听着，如果你要给我们一个换
clothes you need to make sure it's secure. A woman walked right into that room and he said no one was in that area and I said well explain to me how this to change our clothes, you need to make sure it's secure." A woman walked right into that room. And he said, no one was in that area. And I said, well, explain to me how this woman walked in. He said, what'd she look like? And I said, well, she was, I kind of tried to describe her. I was like, as I was describing her, I realized like, I was like, she's wearing a big hat and like a dress.
衣服的地方，你得确保它是安全的。一个女人直接走进了那个房间。他说那个区域没有人，我说，好吧，解释一下这个女人是怎么走进来的。他说，她长什么样？我说，嗯，她，我试图描述她的样子。我说，当我描述她的时候，我意识到，我说，她戴着一顶大帽子，穿着一条裙子。
And sort of, I realized I was describing an old timey lady and then his face got all white and he was like, oh my gosh, you saw the lavender lady. What? Yeah. I'm out at that point. I'm bye bye, bye dinner theater career. Listen, I have to go entertain folks.
某种程度上，我意识到我是在描述一个老派的女士，然后他的脸一下子变得煞白，他说，哦天哪，你看到了薰衣草夫人。什么？对。那一刻我直接退出了。晚宴剧场演员生涯，拜拜了您嘞。听着，我还得去招待观众呢。
They're on their salad course. I've got to get out there and tell them a murder has happened. Wow. Yeah. Oh my gosh, that's creepy. Yeah. Wow you did dinner theater lady you did theater while someone was like buttering a baguette. Well here's the thing we did it between courses so we'd bring everybody in we'd sit them down they're getting their drinks we're handing out slips of paper.
他们正在吃沙拉呢。我得出去告诉他们发生谋杀案了。哇。是的。哦天哪，太毛骨悚然了。是的。哇，你当过晚宴剧场女演员，在别人切法式长棍面包时演过戏。好吧，事情是这样的，我们在上菜间隙表演，所以我们把大家都带进来，让他们坐下，他们拿好饮料，我们发纸条。
It was our job during this mingle to find the people who seemed outgoing enough to play the major roles. Because you don't want to give... Wait, wait, the people eating dinner play a part? Oh yes, everybody gets a part. Everybody has a funny name. Someone in the room is the murderer. Oh, I didn't realize that. I thought you were performing a murder mystery while people ate dinner and watched you. No, interactive improvisation slash scripted. We had jokes, we had to keep people kind of on the plot. But you know, you'd walk people to their table, you waiters giving them a drink,
我们在人们社交寒暄的时候，工作就是找出那些看起来足够外向、能扮演主要角色的人。因为你不想给……等等，等等，吃晚餐的人要扮演角色？哦，是的，每个人都有一个角色。每个人都有一个滑稽的名字。房间里有个人是凶手。哦，我没意识到这一点。我以为你们是在人们吃晚餐和看演出时表演谋杀之谜。不，是互动即兴表演结合剧本。我们有笑词，我们得让大家跟着剧情走。但你知道的，你会把人们带到桌子旁，服务员给他们端饮料，
you're hobnobbing with them in character. And you find the people that seem like they can play the different roles. And then you've got these slips of paper and you hand it to them and then later you'd be like, where's Bobby Oilton? Bobby Oilton? Oh yes, I saw you when you came in. Bobby, what do you have to say for yourself? And then he has to read off of his little slip of paper. Oh my gosh, you were Michael Scott. Yes, I sort of was. You were Caleb Crawdad.
你用角色的身份与他们攀谈。然后你会找出那些看起来能够扮演不同角色的人。接着你手里拿着这些纸条递给他们，过一会儿你就会说，鲍比·奥尔顿在哪里？鲍比·奥尔顿？哦是的，我看到你进来的时侯了。鲍比，你有什么要为自己辩解的？然后他就得照着他的小纸条念。哦天哪，你就是迈克尔·斯科特。是的，我有点像是。你是小龙虾卡勒布。
I was sort of Caleb Crawdad. I was sort of Caleb Crawdad, yeah. Wow. Yeah, so I did that for two years. But I got 50 bucks a night. That was like good money for acting, for doing what I loved. I need mom detectives to go
我有点像是小龙虾卡勒布。我有点像是小龙虾卡勒布，是的。哇。是的，所以我干了两年。但我一晚上能拿50块钱。对于演戏、做自己喜欢的事来说，那算是不错的收入了。我需要《妈妈侦探》去
to a murder mystery dinner theater. Put it on a card, Jenna. Yeah, we should investigate the Lavender Lady sighting. Yes! We'll get to the bottom of it. We will, but we'll have to be in character to wear outfits. Yes, because we'll pretend like we're part of the dinner theater. We'll pretend we're part of the show.
参加谋杀之谜晚宴剧场。写在卡片上，珍娜。对，我们应该调查一下薰衣草夫人的目击事件。太棒了！我们要查个水落石出。会的，不过我们得扮演角色，穿上戏服。对，因为我们要假装自己是晚宴剧场的一部分。假装我们是演出的一部分。
My God, it writes itself! My God! If I see this on TV one day, I'm going to be so pissed. I'm going to kick someone's ass if it's not you and I. I know. Kicking some butts. All right. Let's take a break and call our agents. We're back, and today only. Dwight Schrute presents this year in martial arts, colon updates, advancements, and etc.
天哪，这剧本自己就写出来了！天哪！如果有一天我在电视上看到这个，我会气死的。如果不是你和我，我会狠狠踢某人的屁股。我知道。大显身手。好了。我们休息一下，给经纪人打个电话。我们回来了，仅限今天。德鲁·施鲁特为您呈现今年的武术回顾，冒号，更新、进展等等。
Yes, like Jim said, there's always lots of changes to the 1,000-year-old martial arts traditions. Dwight's going to start with Phyllis. I clock some moves. Phyllis charges Dwight with what looks to be a two-finger eye jab. Dwight stops her with an arm block that I guess would have broken her arm and then he's going to flip her over. Yeah. He tries to engage Kevin. Kevin's a big no. And all of this is going to lead to
是的，就像吉姆说的，有一千多年历史的传统武术总是会有很多变化。德鲁要从菲利斯开始。我记录下了一些招式。菲利斯向德鲁发起进攻，看起来像是双指戳眼。德鲁用手臂格挡阻止了她，我猜这本该折断她的手臂，然后他要把她过肩摔。对。他试图和凯文交手。凯文坚决拒绝。所有这一切都将导致
Dwight fighting himself. Yes. I'd like to point out in this scene at 39 seconds, Meredith is wearing the designer sweater vest again. I clocked that too. I mean I feel like this is some sort of personal trolling of me. Well I have a few tidbits about this cold open. Oh really? I have some as well. Well I'll start by saying we got a lot of mail of people asking if Dwight's self-fight was choreographed.
德鲁自己和自己打。是的。我想指出，在这场戏的第39秒，梅雷迪思又穿着那件设计师毛衣背心了。我也注意到了。我的意思是，我觉得这有点像是对我个人的恶搞。好吧，关于这个冷场开场，我有一些小花絮。哦，真的吗？我也有一些。好吧，我先说，我们收到了很多邮件，有人问德鲁的自我搏击是不是排练好的。
And I would like to tell you guys that was all Rain Wilson. Bravo, Rain! Yes. He came up with all of those moves based on descriptions in the script. We did have our stunt coordinator, Eric Sulky, on board for the day just to make sure that Rain didn't actually hurt himself. Well, in the DVD commentary, Danny shared that the original version of this cold open ended with Dwight and Michael kicking each other in the groin. Oh, yeah. But instead, they went with a pitch from Jen Salata where Dwight fights himself instead.
我想告诉大家，那全都是雷恩·威尔逊自己发挥的。干得好，雷恩！是的。他根据剧本中的描述想出了所有这些招式。我们的特技协调员埃里克·萨尔基当天确实在场，以确保雷恩不会真的弄伤自己。好吧，在DVD评论音轨中，丹尼透露这个冷场开场的最初版本是以德鲁和迈克尔互相踢对方下体结束的。哦，是的。但他们没有采用这个，而是采纳了珍·萨拉塔的一个点子，改成德鲁和自己打。
It still ends with Dwight punching himself in the groin, but it was originally scripted to be a self-kick in the groin. It said this. How do you kick yourself in the groin? Exactly. Yeah. Here's what the script said, quote,
虽然最后仍然以德鲁给自己下体一拳结束，但原本剧本写的是自己踢自己下体。剧本是这样写的。怎么能自己踢自己下体呢？确实。剧本是这么写的，引述如下：
Dwight snaps his leg up and kicks himself in the balls. Dwight's face shows equally the pain of the kick and the pride of winning. That's so great. On the day they realized there was no way for Rain to self kick himself in the balls, that it was just sort of physically impossible. However, Danny said in an interview
德鲁猛地抬起腿，踢了自己的蛋蛋。德鲁的脸上既流露出挨踢的痛苦，又流露出获胜的骄傲。太棒了。到了拍摄当天，他们意识到雷恩根本不可能自己踢到自己的蛋蛋，这在生理上几乎是不可能的。然而，丹尼在一次采访中透露
that Greg was convinced there was a way to do it if maybe they could attach a strap to Rain's leg that would help sort of hoist it up somehow. He even sketched it out on the back of his script, which is a very Greg move. Can't you see Greg turning a script over and like sketching out the self groin kick strap? Here's how it works, here's the mechanics. I want that sketch and I want it in a frame. Right?
格雷格坚信有办法做到这一点，也许他们可以在雷恩的腿上绑一条带子，某种程度上帮助把腿吊起来。他甚至把它画在剧本背面，这非常符合格雷格的风格。难道你想象不到格雷格把剧本翻过来画那个自踢下体固定带的样子吗？原理是这样的，力学机制是这样的。我想要那张草图，而且我要把它装进框里。对吧？
Where is that sketch? In the end, obviously this was not happening, so they had Rain punch himself in the groin. Greg shared that he really enjoyed directing the cold open and the tag for this episode because they were like mini action movies or the closest thing our show got to little action sequences. And Jenna Ellie shared something.
那张草图在哪儿？最后，显然这行不通，所以他们让雷恩给了自己下体一拳。格雷格分享说，他非常喜欢导演这一集的冷场开场和尾声，因为它们就像是微型动作电影，或者说我们的剧所能做到的最接近小型动作序列的东西。而且珍娜，艾莉分享了一点。
She said the cold open was filmed the morning of the Emmys. Oh, so after Rain beat himself up, he had to go to the Emmys? We all did. Wow. We worked that day. We have shared this before, that many times we worked right up until an event and we would have to get ready at the set.
她说冷场开场是在艾美奖颁奖典礼那天早晨拍摄的。哦，所以雷恩把自己暴揍一顿之后，还得去参加艾美奖？我们全都去了。哇。我们那天工作了。我们以前分享过，很多时候我们一直工作到活动开始前，然后得在片场做好准备。
Yeah. And the Emmys were traditionally on a Monday night. Yeah. Which was rough because it would be like the beginning of your work week. Oh, and you'd be wrecked. For the whole rest of the week. Wow. We worked this day and then we went to the Emmys. Oh one last thing, I have a Dwight flyer count. Oh. Because clearly you need to have multiple flyers for your year in martial art update. We have one on each of Jim's glass walls and we have one on the door by accounting.
是的。而且艾美奖传统上是在周一晚上举行。是的。这很难熬，因为那相当于你工作周的开始。哦，而且你会累垮的。接下来的一整周都是如此。哇。我们那天工作了，然后去了艾美奖。哦，还有最后一点，我统计了德鲁传单的数量。哦。因为很明显，你的武术年度更新需要有多张传单。我们在吉姆的每一面玻璃墙上贴了一张，在会计部旁边的门上贴了一张。
Three in view during the whole cold open. I don't know about the rest of the bullpen. Or the kitchen or the break room. I know. I'm sure they're everywhere. They're not there for the rest of the episode, but there's three visible for the cold open. Well, now we're going to get into this episode. It opens with some weird banter between Michael and Andy about sculpting stand-up comedy. And it's interrupted by Dwight receiving an email. And Michael's like, you need to be more specific. I get like eight emails a day. Eight, Jenna.
整个冷场开场期间视野里一共有三张。至于办公区其他地方我就不知道了。或者厨房和茶水间。我知道。我敢肯定到处都是。在这一集的剩余部分它们不在那儿了，但在冷场开场时能看到三张。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集正片了。开场是迈克尔和安迪之间关于塑造单口喜剧的一些奇怪闲聊。然后被德鲁收到的一封电子邮件打断了。迈克尔说，你需要更具体一点。我一天大概收到八封邮件。八封，珍娜。
He gets eight. It's really weird that before we started recording today, we were discussing our email inboxes. Yeah. So guys, Sam and Jenna are really tidy about their email inbox. Like, they get to zero and then they ask me what my inbox said and my inbox says 1,582. And Sam and I are still processing that and we're... It gave you like hives for a minute. Yeah, we're having a hard time. I don't mean this as an attack, but the way you live is chaos.
他收了八封。真奇怪，在我们今天开始录音前，我们还在讨论我们的电子邮件收件箱。对啊。所以大家，萨姆和珍娜对她们的电子邮件收件箱非常整洁。比如，她们清空到零，然后她们问我的收件箱显示多少，我的收件箱显示1,582。萨姆和我还在消化这个数字，我们……这让你起了一身鸡皮疙瘩吧。对啊，我们很难接受。我不是故意针对你，但你的生活方式简直是一团糟。
Sam's at zero right now. I'm at 10 unread emails. Actually, do you remember in the break, there was a great Jenna moment where you were looking for an email and you couldn't find it and Jenna goes, oh, I'm sorry, can you not? Yeah, I was like, oh, you can't find the email I sent you? I think I sent it on Monday or Tuesday. Well, I got a few emails since I last checked and now I'm 1,583.
萨姆目前是零。我有10封未读邮件。其实，你还记得在中场休息时，有一个珍娜的高光时刻，你当时在找一封邮件却找不到，珍娜说，哦，不好意思，你能不能别……对，我当时说，哦，你找不到我发给你的邮件？我想我是周一或周二发给你的。好吧，自从我上次查看后，我又收到了一些邮件，现在我有1,583封了。
See, you do what Lee does, which is if you can tell that it's something you don't need to read, like it's, I don't know, an ad or something, you don't delete it, you just skip it. And then it stays unread. Yes. I delete those. I don't want that cluttering me.
你看，你和李做的一样，如果你能看出那是些你不需要读的东西，比如，我不知道，是个广告什么的，你不会删掉它，你只是跳过它。然后它就保持未读状态。是的。我会删掉那些。我不希望它们把我的地方弄乱。
No, you do it right. That's the way you should do it. But if it doesn't bother you, then you're not doing it wrong. It would bother me if I did it your way. Well Michael only gets eight, so I guess he's not super stressed out. I guess he's not. The email that Dwight is talking about is from David Wallace, and it is referring to an article in the journal.
不，你做得对。这才是你应该做的做法。但如果这不困扰你，那你就没做错。如果我用你的方式做，那倒会困扰我。好吧，迈克尔只收到八封，所以我想他压力不是很大。我想他确实不大。德鲁正在谈论的那封邮件来自大卫·华尔士，里面提到了《华尔街日报》上的一篇文章。
I mean, the wall, as Michael calls it. Oh, the wall, right? Oscar finds the article, but in order to read it, you have to pay an extra $1.99 to get past the paywall. Danny shared that they spent like five hours researching the rules of the Wall Street Journal's paywall at that time. He said, apparently, if you're referencing a specific publication, you cannot make up a fact like that that's not true. Oh, so at that time, that was the rule of the paywall. Interesting. Why did it take five hours to get that information? I think they just had to get it correctly and Jenna they didn't have the Google back then.
我是说，华尔街日报，迈克尔是这么叫的。哦，华尔街日报，对吧？奥斯卡找到了这篇文章，但为了阅读它，你得额外支付1.99美元来突破付费墙。丹尼透露，他们花了大约五个小时来研究当时《华尔街日报》付费墙的规则。他说，显然，如果你在引用一个特定的出版物，你不能凭空捏造一个并不真实的所谓事实。哦，所以当时，那是付费墙的规则。有趣。为什么获取这个信息花了五个小时？我想他们只是必须弄清楚，而且珍娜，他们那时候没有谷歌。
They had Google back then. It was like 2009. They didn't have the same search engines. 100% they did. How old do you think Google is? It's new. Google is new. I'm going to Google, when did Google start? Well, I don't know why it took them five hours, but that's what he said on the DVD commentary. They had to be thorough, Jenna. What were you Googling in 2009?
他们那时候有谷歌。那是2009年左右。他们当时没有那种搜索引擎。百分之百有。你觉得谷歌诞生多久了？它很新。谷歌很新。我要谷歌一下，谷歌是什么时候开始的？好吧，我不知道为什么花了他们五个小时，但他在DVD评论音轨里就是这么说的。他们必须做到严谨，珍娜。你在2009年用谷歌搜什么？
Don't put this on us. Any number I'm not saying you, I'm saying you. I mean, people listening. Hold on. What did you Google in 2009? Google started September 4th, 1998. But their search engine. I'm going to get more specific.
别把这甩给我们。不管什么数字我不是说你，我是说你们。我是说，听众们。等一下。你在2009年用谷歌搜了什么？谷歌成立于1998年9月4日。但他们的搜索引擎。我要更具体一点。
Thank you. When did the Google search engine really come into effect? Not really come into effect. When did people start using the Google search engine? 1998. And it really became popular around 2000. Thank you, Sam. I don't believe it.
谢谢。谷歌搜索引擎是什么时候真正投入使用的？不是真正投入使用。人们是什么时候开始使用谷歌搜索引擎的？1998年。而且它大约在2000年左右真正流行起来。谢谢你，萨姆。我不信。
No one was Googling until like two years ago. Oh, God. I don't know. Yeah. OK. Everyone, Android discovered Google a couple of years ago. Listen, I don't know why it took them five hours, but they clearly had to get it right. Maybe they had to get on the phone with someone. I'm not judging our writers, Jenna. I just thought it was a long time.
直到大概两年前才有人在用谷歌。哦，天哪。我不知道。好吧。大家，安卓是前几年才发现谷歌的。听着，我不知道为什么花了他们五个小时，但他们显然必须弄对。也许他们不得不跟某个人通电话。我不是在评判我们的编剧，珍娜。我只是觉得时间有点长。
Well, Jenna's judging you guys. Here's what I want to point out about this scene, as we're all gathered around the computer and everybody's reading this article off of Oscar's computer, we're learning that Dunder Mifflin might be, I guess, going into debt, going under, filing for bankruptcy. Angela, this entire scene, you are blocking me. You cannot see my face in this scene because you are standing directly in front of me. And then finally, you move out of the way and John blocks me. I took pictures.
好吧，珍娜在评判你们。下面是我想要指出关于这一幕的一点，当我们都围在电脑旁，每个人都在读奥斯卡电脑上的这篇文章时，我们得知邓德米夫林可能，我猜，要负债了，要破产了，要申请破产保护了。安吉拉，这一整场戏，你都在挡着我。在这场戏里根本看不到我的脸，因为你直接站在我前面。然后最后，你让开后，约翰又挡住我了。我拍了照片。
Did you take a picture? Yes, I did. It was so funny to me because one of you is blocking me the whole time. We talked that morning and we were like, today is the day, John. You and I, I'm gonna wear my three inch heels and I'm gonna make sure I block that shot. Here, I put them all together. We really are. Why didn't anyone say anything? I don't know.
你拍了照片吗？是的，我拍了。这对我来说太搞笑了，因为你们俩一直轮流挡着我。我们那天早上还聊过，我们说，今天就是这一天，约翰。你和我，我要穿上我三英寸的高跟鞋，确保我能挡住那个镜头。瞧，我把它们都拼在一起了。我们真的是。为什么当时没有人说点什么？我不知道。
So we don't know how Pam feels about this article because we can never see her. You can't see her face. Sorry. I rarely was able to block anyone. Personal victory, I guess. I know. Well, what's funny is they all stop at the $1.99.
所以我们不知道帕姆对这篇文章有何感受，因为我们永远看不到她。你看不到她的脸。抱歉。我很少能挡住别人。算是一次个人胜利吧。我知道。好吧，有趣的是他们都在1.99美元那里停下了。
They're like, oh, I guess we're not gonna know what really happens with the company. And then Jim enters in his information. Yes. This sends Michael on a spiral and he calls David Wallace, but David's in a meeting. I was curious about two moments in this scene. Okay.
他们就像是，哦，我想我们不会知道公司到底会怎么样了。然后吉姆输入了他的信息。是的。这让迈克尔陷入了崩溃，他给大卫·华尔士打电话，但大卫正在开会。我对这场戏中的两个时刻很好奇。好的。
One was I was wondering if Steve improvised the way he said, you should spy on him, wouldn't that be so hilarious? Okay. I was like, did they tell Steve to say it like that? I went to the script and it said on that line in parentheses, Valley Girl. Oh yeah. So they did give him sort of a line read.
一个是我想知道史蒂夫是不是即兴说出那句，“你应该监视他，难道不是很搞笑吗？”好的。我当时想，是有人告诉史蒂夫要那样说的吗？我翻了剧本，那句台词后面的括号里写着：山谷女孩。哦，是的。所以他们确实给了他某种台词语调指导。
Yes. The other thing I was curious about was the line in the script when Michael says, catch you on the flippity flip. I was like, that sounds like something Steve would improvise. No. So that line was in the script too.
是的。我好奇的另一件事是剧本中的那句台词，当迈克尔说：“回头在翻转翻上见。”当时我想，这听起来像是史蒂夫会即兴发挥的东西。不是。所以那句台词也在剧本里。
And Danny shared on the DVD commentary that Gene Stupnitsky actually pitched Catch You on the Flippity Flip for a different episode. And the writers loved it, but it didn't make it in. So they kept trying to get this line in. Oh my gosh. Episode after episode, and they finally got it in. Well, you know when Michael goes to the bathroom
而且丹尼在DVD评论音轨里透露，吉恩·斯普尼茨基实际上为另一集提议过“回头在翻转翻上见”。编剧们非常喜欢，但没能用上。所以他们一直在努力把这句台词塞进去。哦天哪。一集又一集，他们终于把它加进去了。好吧，你知道当迈克尔去洗手间
and he's been vomiting, but then he tries to tell Kevin he was just pooping. We had a fan question from Kelly C. in Michigan, who wrote the line, just pooping, you know how I be? That was Danny. Danny said it's one of the lines he's most proud of. It's a great line. Oh, I also wanted to say one more thing, Angela.
他一直在呕吐，但他却试图告诉凯文他只是在大便。我们收到了来自密歇根州凯利C.的粉丝提问，是谁写的这句台词，“只是大便，你知道我是怎么样的？”那是丹尼。丹尼说这是他最引以为傲的台词之一。这是一句很棒的台词。哦，我还想说一件事，安吉拉。
Back in the office when Michael calls and tries to get in touch with David Wallace, once again we had Suzanne Watson as the voice of David's assistant, Stephanie. And she is always great. So great. So in the script, Jenna, they built in more scenes to show Michael really spiraling.
回到办公室里，当迈克尔打电话试图联系大卫·华尔士时，我们再次请到了苏珊·沃森来为大卫的助理斯蒂芬妮配音。她总是那么棒。太棒了。所以珍娜，在剧本中，他们加入了更多的场景来展现迈克尔真正的崩溃。
You know, he calls David, he vomits in the bathroom. He also just starts pacing in front of Erin's reception, waiting for the phone call, waiting to see if she signals him that someone's calling. It's so funny. I want to play it for you. It's in the deleted scenes. The first part I'm calling, Michael is pissed. If it's not for me, don't make it look like it's for me, okay?
你知道的，他给大卫打电话，在洗手间呕吐。他还开始在艾琳的前台前面踱步，等待电话，等待看她是否向自己示意有人打电话来。太搞笑了。我想放给你们听。在删减片段里。第一部分我打电话时，迈克尔气炸了。如果不是找我的，别搞得好像是找我的一样，好吗？
I'm sorry. Because I'm going to **** my pants. Okay? I'm sorry. Because I'm going to sh- my pants. Okay, I'm sorry. It's my fault. Michael? Um, I'm sorry before that I did not know what you were talking about. Don't... okay. Do you want anything for-
我很抱歉。因为我要拉裤子了。好吗？我很抱歉。因为我要拉-裤子了。好吧，对不起。是我的错。迈克尔？呃，对不起，我刚才不知道你在说什么。别……好吧。你想为——
Don't even talk. Don't even talk to me. Okay? Alright? If they do call, don't- Only if they call me, then talk to me, okay? All right? If they do call, don't. Only if they call me, then talk to me, okay? If it's anything else, or if you wanna apologize to me for calling me when they weren't calling, then don't do that, all right?
话都别说。别跟我说话。好吗？好吧？如果他们真的打电话来，别——只有他们打给我时，再跟我说话，好吗？好吧？如果他们打电话来，别。只有他们打给我时，再跟我说话，好吗？如果是别的什么事，或者你想为他们没打电话却叫我而向我道歉，那就别那样做，好吗？
Do you understand? You're very, very nice, but you're really, you're kinda pissing me off, okay? Sorry. All right. Did she laugh at the end? No. I thought she lied.
你明白吗？你非常好，但你真的很，你有点把我惹毛了，好吗？抱歉。好吧。她最后笑了吗？没有。我以为她笑了。
I thought she said sorry. So her sorry looks like she's about to laugh, but then she turns it into like a cry. And then poor Erin, she's so confused by Michael, it continues and you've got to hear it. Don't cry. Don't cry, please. Don't cry. Everybody's sort of high strungung so chalk it up to that. We're all in it together.
我以为她说了对不起。所以她道歉的样子看起来像是快要笑了，但接着她把它变成了哭腔。然后可怜的艾琳，她被迈克尔搞得一头雾水，这种情况还在继续，你们得听听这个。别哭。别哭，求你了。别哭。大家都挺紧绷的，所以把这归咎于那个吧。我们都在一条船上。
Well, don't laugh either. Just don't cry and don't laugh. Good? All right. It's such a funny moment. Oh my gosh. I love the dynamic between those two. They really did a good job of creating a different dynamic than what Pam and Michael had.
好吧，也别笑。就是别哭也别笑。好吗？好吧。真是个搞笑的时刻。哦天哪。我喜欢这两个人之间的化学反应。他们确实做得很好，创造了一种不同于帕姆和迈克尔之间的化学反应。
Yeah, I mean... She so earnestly wants to help him. She so earnestly wants to be liked by him. Yeah. And Michael with Pam, it's the reverse. Michael wants to be in Pam's life. Yes. Well, instead of all that, he's going to go into his office and play the Sean Mullins song Lullaby. I found out from Randy Cordray that it cost us $45,000
是的，我是说……她那么真诚地想要帮助他。她那么真诚地想要获得他的喜爱。是的。而迈克尔对帕姆，则恰好相反。迈克尔想要进入帕姆的生活。是的。好吧，他没有去做那些，而是走进办公室播放了肖恩·马林斯的歌曲《摇篮曲》。我从兰迪·科德雷那里得知，为了在剧中播放这首歌、使用这个片段，
to have this song in the show, to have this clip. Well, I have a background catch at five minutes 29 seconds. Michael says he needs more Mullins and he hits the volume button on his keyboard repeatedly. Okay. Greg shared that they worked really hard in editing to get that sound to match Steve hitting the keyboard. And Danny shared that after the episode aired,
我们花费了45,000美元。好吧，我在5分29秒有一个背景抓包。迈克尔说他需要更多马林斯的歌，然后他反复按下键盘上的音量键。好的。格雷格分享说，他们在剪辑时非常努力，想让那个声音与史蒂夫敲击键盘的动作匹配。而丹尼分享说，在这集播出后，
the comment boards were full of people saying that that was a Mac sound and Michael is using a PC. Oh my gosh. Is that funny? Yes. Oh wow, they picked the wrong volume up sound. Well, Jim's going to come in during all of this. He's like, Michael, you have to pull it together.
评论区到处都是人说那是苹果电脑的声音，而迈克尔用的是个人电脑。哦天哪。是不是很搞笑？是的。哦哇，他们选错了音量调高音效。好吧，这一切发生时吉姆进来了。他说，迈克尔，你得振作起来。
Like basically he's saying, you're our leader and if you're freaking out, it's freaking out everyone. We need to just make this a normal day. What's on the agenda? Michael's like, well, we're supposed to have a staff meeting. And Jim's like, great! Right. Everyone in the conference room.
基本上他是说，你是我们的领导，如果你吓坏了，那会让所有人都吓坏的。我们只需要让这成为平常的一天。议程上有什么？迈克尔说，好吧，我们本该有个员工会议。吉姆说，太好了！对。大家去会议室。
Have we ever seen Jim so excited to go into the conference room before? No, but he says he only slacks off when things are good. So I guess, you know, when the shit hits the fan, he becomes very professional. It's so funny because I feel like people would be equally freaked out by Jim suddenly having a work ethic.
我们以前见过吉姆这么兴奋地去会议室吗？没有，但他说他只有在事情顺利时才会偷懒。所以我想，你知道的，当麻烦来临的时候，他变得非常专业。这太搞笑了，因为我觉得大家会同样被吉姆突然展现出的职业道德吓坏。
They'd be like, uh-oh, uh-oh. What's happening? Stuff is bad. Jim wants to work. Yeah. Mom is getting serious. What's going on? Exactly. In the conference room, Jim addresses the group. At 5 minutes 56 seconds, Ryan is wearing glasses. That was my big takeaway. minutes 56 seconds Ryan is wearing glasses. That was my big takeaway. Ryan is wearing glasses and everyone's in the conference room but Kelly. Where's Kelly? Where is Kelly? Let me tell you she's only in one scene this entire episode. What was she doing? Where was Mindy? I don't know.
他们会想，呃哦，呃哦。发生什么事了？情况很糟糕。吉姆想工作了。是的。妈要认真了。怎么回事？完全如此。在会议室里，吉姆向大家讲话。在5分56秒，瑞恩戴着眼镜。那是我的重大发现。分56秒瑞恩戴着眼镜。那是我的重大发现。瑞恩戴着眼镜，除了凯莉，大家都在会议室里。凯莉呢？凯利在哪儿？让我告诉你，她这一整集只出现了一个场景。她在干嘛？敏迪去哪儿了？我不知道。
Michael has to leave the conference room to take a phone call. And Dwight has one of my favorite lines in the episode. What is it? He says, he needs me. Seat saved infinity. Aw. Our kids save seats. They're still in that phase of their life.
迈克尔不得不离开会议室去接个电话。而德鲁拥有我在这一集中最喜欢的台词之一。是什么？他说，他需要我。座位保留到永远。啊。我们的孩子会占座。他们正处于人生的那个阶段。
We're like, I want that seat. That's my seat. Seat saved infinity. Dwight came to play. Well, Michael's going to come back. His phone call was bad news, Angela. Yeah. Very bad news.
我们就像是，我想要那个座位。那是我的座位。座位保留到永远。德鲁真是来状态了。好吧，迈克尔要回来了。他的电话是个坏消息，安吉拉。是的。非常坏的消息。
There's been a murder in Savannah. And that was the end of the act break. It was supposed to be. They were supposed to go to commercial. Yeah. And then when they were editing, they thought that would be stressful. They thought it would be mean also to the audience.
萨凡纳发生了一起谋杀案。这就是幕间休息的结束。本来应该是这样的。他们本该进入广告。是的。然后在剪辑时，他们觉得那会很有压力。他们觉得这对观众来说也有点刻薄。
But instead, we have this Michael talking head where we also see him going through his closet. He's looking for something. His office armoire. Yes. There are many games inside and we realize there has not been a real murder, but we're going to play a murder mystery game. Yes, because Michael thinks games help distract you
但相反，我们有了这个迈克尔的采访镜头，同时我们看到他在翻找自己的衣柜。他在找什么东西。他的办公室大衣柜。是的。里面有很多游戏，我们意识到并没有发生真正的谋杀案，但我们要玩一个谋杀之谜游戏。是的，因为迈克尔认为游戏有助于分散注意力
in stressful situations. Yes. Did you see the games in his armoire? I did. Let's read them off. All right, I don't know if we wrote them in the same order. Well, you do one, I'll do one. All right, connect four.
在压力大的情况下。是的。你看到他衣柜里的游戏了吗？看到了。我们把它们念出来吧。好吧，我不知道我们写的是不是同一个顺序。好吧，你念一个，我念一个。好吧，常青棋（Connect Four）。
Stratego. Operation. Trouble. Sorry. Risk. Battleship. That's it connect four. Stratego. Operation. Trouble. Sorry. Risk. Battleship. That's it. That's what I had. Me too. Well, the game he brings in to the conference room is called Bells, Bourbon, and Bullets, a murder mystery dinner party game. Yes, we got a lot of mail. People wanted to know is this a real game? Can I buy it? Can I play it? Well, it was a made-up game.
陆战棋（Stratego）。吉屋迷魂（Operation）。困惑棋（Trouble）。妙探寻凶（Sorry）。风险大作战（Risk）。战舰棋（Battleship）。就是这样，常青棋。陆战棋。吉屋迷魂。困惑棋。妙探寻凶。风险大作战。战舰棋。就是这样。我记的也是这些。我也是。好吧，他带进会议室的游戏叫做《铃铛、波旁威士忌与子弹》，一个谋杀之谜晚宴派对游戏。是的，我们收到了很多邮件。人们想知道这是个真实的游戏吗？我能买到吗？我能玩吗？好吧，这是一个虚构的游戏。
The box and all the cards and the props inside were created just for our episode. The box and the logos were designed by our new graphic designer Henry Sane, and Phil Shea worked with Danny Chun to come up with all of the props and paraphernalia that each character would have. And Randy even shared with us that the box and cards were printed by Phil's go-to prop manufacturing company called the Hand Prop Room. Now we know where all this stuff comes from! Well, they crushed it. I thought it looked so amazing. I zoomed in on it. I loved the catchphrase on the front. What was it? Everything you need to have a deadly good time.
盒子、所有的卡片和里面的道具都是专为我们这一集创作的。盒子和标志是由我们的新平面设计师亨利·萨恩设计的，菲尔·谢伊与丹尼·陈合作想出了每个角色拥有的所有道具和随身物品。兰迪甚至跟我们分享说，盒子和卡片是由菲尔常用的道具制造公司“手作道具屋”印刷的。现在我们知道这些东西都是从哪儿来的了！好吧，他们太绝了。我觉得看起来太棒了。我把图片放大了。我非常喜欢正面的标语。是什么？拥有致命美好时光所需的一切。
Ooh. Ooh. And there was like a fan with blood on it and like a pistol and a glass of bourbon. I love it. Jim is not for this. Jim does not want this, but Michael's like, you owe me one. Tube City. Tube City.
哦。哦。还有一个带血的扇子、一把手枪和一杯波旁威士忌。我太喜欢了。吉姆不赞成这个。吉姆不想玩这个，但迈克尔说，你欠我一次。管道城。管道城。
Yeah. He shut down Tube City, so he owes Michael one. Tube City is a bunch of tubes with a hamster inside that was going to go all over the whole office. We had a fan question from Emmy in Baltimore, Maryland. Who set up Tube City? Phil Shea? Yes, Emmy.
是的。他关掉了管道城，所以他欠迈克尔一次。管道城是一堆里面装着仓鼠的管道，这些管道原本要通往整个办公室。我们收到了来自马里兰州巴尔的摩的艾米的粉丝提问。谁搭建了管道城？菲尔·谢伊？是的，艾米。
Mm-hmm. Yes. And the hamsters were provided by Bob Dunn's Animal Services. Who set up Tube City? Phil Shea? Yes, Emmy. Mm-hmm. Yes, and the hamsters were provided by Bob Dunn's Animal Services. Denise Sanders was our hamster wrangler. Greg shared they only had half an hour to shoot the whole B-roll of Tube City. Oh my God.
嗯哼。是的。而且仓鼠是由鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司提供的。谁搭建了管道城？菲尔·谢伊？是的，艾米。嗯哼。是的，仓鼠是由鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司提供的。丹尼斯·桑德斯是我们的仓鼠管理员。格雷格分享说，他们只有半个小时来拍摄管道城的所有B面镜头。哦天哪。
Not a lot of time. No. And he said that this whole B-roll idea was kind of an afterthought, and so they really didn't have a ton of time to do it. Tube City made me laugh out loud. Laugh so hard. The little hamster and the very end, he's just a cute little hamster nose coming out of there.
时间不多。没有。而且他说整个B面镜头的创意有点像是个事后想法，所以他们确实没有太多时间去拍。管道城把我逗得哈哈大笑。笑得太厉害了。最后那只小仓鼠，它毛茸茸的小仓鼠鼻子从那里探出来。
I know. Well back in the conference room Michael plays the recording that sets up the whole murder mystery game and I am so sorry to say that despite my Googling. Mm-hmm. That you just learned how to do in like the last five years. Just a couple years ago. And Randy's research, we could not find the name of the person whose voice is on the tape. Anywhere.
我知道。好吧，回到会议室，迈克尔播放了那段奠定整个谋杀之谜游戏基础的录音，我非常遗憾地宣布，尽管我进行了谷歌搜索。嗯哼。就是你刚刚在过去五年左右学会的那种。就在几年前。加上兰迪的研究，我们在任何地方都找不到磁带上那个人的声音是谁。
So listen, if you are the voice of Bells, Bullets, and Bourbon, will you let us know? You can write to us at officeladiesatearwolf.com. We'd love to hear from ya. Well, this is what the voice on the CD player said. Should I do it in an accent? Please, please, Angela. Okay, who knows how this is gonna go. August the 5th, 1955.
所以听着，如果你是《铃铛、子弹与波旁威士忌》的配音，能让我们知道吗？你可以给我们写信，邮箱是officeladiesatearwolf.com。我们很想听到你的声音。好吧，CD播放器里的声音是这么说的。我要用口音读吗？求你了，求你了，安吉拉。好吧，不知道这会变成什么样。1955年8月5日。
It's a sad day down here in Savannah. Local magnet Bill Bourbon was killed last night, and all y'all have congregated tonight for a meal to celebrate Bill as he passes on to his great reward. You're not just here to pay your respects. You have to figure out which of y'all is the no-count scoundrel who killed him. That feels good. I'm ready for my dinner theater. You'd be great.
萨凡纳今天是个悲伤的日子。当地大亨比尔·波旁昨晚被杀，你们今晚齐聚一堂，举行晚宴来庆祝比尔前往他的伟大奖赏。你们不仅仅是为了表示敬意。你们必须弄清楚你们中间哪个是不争气的无赖杀了他。感觉挺不错的。我已经准备好去演晚宴剧场了。你会很棒的。
You'd love it. It's a lot of improv, Angela. I'd have a great time. And I also love like vintage costumes. Oh, we got to do one of these. Nifty 50s murder mystery dinner theater. A special episode of Mom detective i mean god we just don't have enough time to do it all michael starts passing out the character cards and the props
你会喜欢的。里面有很多即兴表演，安吉拉。我会玩得很开心。而且我也喜欢复古服装。哦，我们得玩一次这个。疯狂50年代谋杀之谜晚宴剧场。妈妈侦探特别篇，我的天，我们简直没有足够的时间做完所有这些。迈克尔开始分发角色卡片和道具。
angela does not like her character no we had a fan catch from katie k in san jose california i think i have a Southern Angela catch. When Angela says, I don't like my character at 8 minutes and 54 seconds, Cassie pulled an audio clip. Let's hear it. Michael, I don't like this game. It's scary. It's not scary.
安吉拉不喜欢她的角色。不，我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州圣何塞的凯蒂·K.的粉丝抓包，我想我找到了一个南方安吉拉的抓包。当安吉拉在8分54秒说“我不喜欢我的角色”时，卡西截取了一段音频剪辑。我们听听看。迈克尔，我不喜欢这个游戏。太吓人了。一点也不吓人。
I don't like my character. Who are you? Voodoo Mama Juju, the witch doctor of the Savannah swamps. I'm not comfortable with this. There's so many words that are southern. I don't like this game. Swamps. I don't like my character.
我不喜欢我的角色。你是谁？巫毒妈妈朱朱，萨凡纳沼泽的巫医。我对这个很不习惯。有这么多词都是南方的。我不喜欢这个游戏。沼泽。我不喜欢我的角色。
I don't like my character. I don't like the game. I don't like my character. It's scary and it's set in a swamp. Yeah. Voodoo Mama Juju. Yep. I hear a hint of it.
我不喜欢我的角色。我不喜欢这个游戏。我不喜欢我的角色。这很吓人，而且背景设定在一个沼泽里。对。巫毒妈妈朱朱（Voodoo Mama Juju）。没错。我听到了一点它的痕迹。
I don't think it's your strongest accent slip, but I hear a hint. It's always there, guys. I wanna point something out. As we rewatch these episodes, Jenna and I have talked about this. Sometimes we'll just watch a scene and a flood of memories come back
我觉得这不算你最严重的一次口音滑铁卢，但我确实听到了一点。它一直都在，伙计们。我想指出一件事。当我们重看这些剧集时，珍娜和我讨论过这件事。有时我们只是看一个场景，就会涌现出大量记忆，
that we had totally forgotten about. It's like in a little folder in your brain that hasn't been opened in years. As I watched this scene, when Angela goes to leave and Michael says, there'll be baby carrots, and she pivots back to her seat, my skirt is so bunched up. And I instantly remembered that this was the week I wanted to wear tights. I was cold. I never wore tights and I wore thick winter tights, but I was wearing a gray pencil skirt that would climb up all day because of the static and the tights.
那些我们完全忘光的记忆。就像你大脑里的一个小文件夹，已经好几年没打开了。当我看到这个场景时，安吉拉要离开，迈克尔说，会有小胡萝卜，然后她转身回到座位上，我的裙子缩得好厉害。我立刻想起来，那是我想穿连裤袜的一周。我很冷。我从来不穿连裤袜，但我穿了厚厚的冬日连裤袜，不过我穿了一条灰色的铅笔裙，因为静电和连裤袜的关系，裙子一整天都在往上跑。
And I wrestled that skirt this whole episode. And when I watched this moment with the baby carrots, I was like, oh my gosh, that was the week with the skirt that kept crawling up my legs. They used to spray me with static guard. Yeah, it didn't matter though because of my tights. Anyway, this is the week I wrestled a skirt. Sometimes those are the things you remember when you rewatch a show.
整集节目我都在和那条裙子做斗争。当我看到小胡萝卜这个时刻时，我心想，哦天哪，就是那周，裙子一直往我腿上爬。他们以前会给我喷防静电喷雾。对啊，不过因为我的连裤袜，喷了也没用。总之，这就是我跟裙子搏斗的一周。有时，这些就是你重看一部剧时会记住的事情。
And you know what? We are going to leave no detail unturned in this rewatch. That's right. In this oral history that we're creating for all time. We're leaving nothing out. Nothing out. We are gonna tell you the week that Jenna's allergies were bad. Yep.
你知道吗？在这场重看之旅中，我们将事无巨细，不放过任何一个细节。没错。在这部我们要永远流传下去的口述历史中。我们什么都不会漏掉。什么都不漏。我们要告诉你珍娜过敏很严重的那周。没错。
And she sneezed a bunch. Mm-hmm. And this is the Skirt Bunch. This is the Skirt Bunch. Forever to be known now as the Skirt Bunch episode. We got a continuity catch from Leah in New Albany, Indiana, who says, I think I have a continuity catch. So, you know, Michael gets mad and he takes Oscar's Blackberry at nine minutes, 25 seconds. Michael is seen holding it in his hand at nine
她打了一堆喷嚏。嗯哼。这就是“裙子帮”。这就是“裙子帮”。从今以后，它永远被称为“裙子帮”那一集。我们收到了印第安纳州新奥尔巴尼的莉亚发来的一条穿帮镜头捉虫，她说，我觉得我发现了一个穿帮。所以你看，迈克尔生气了，在9分25秒时拿走了奥斯卡的黑莓手机。在9分
minutes, 44 seconds. But then at nine minutes, 46 seconds seconds when Pam stands up to do her character intro, Oscar is looking down again, like maybe he's looking at his blackberry, and then at 9 minutes 59 seconds the camera switches angles and you can clearly see that Oscar has his blackberry back. Good catch! I know! I thought that was pretty good. Yeah. Well speaking of Pam does offer to go first and
44秒时，可以看到迈克尔手里拿着它。但接着在9分46秒时，当潘站起来做她的角色介绍时，奥斯卡又低下了头，好像在看他的黑莓手机，然后在9分59秒时，镜头切换了角度，你可以清楚地看到奥斯卡又拿回了他的黑莓手机。抓得好！我知道！我觉得这挺厉害的。对。说到潘，她确实主动提出第一个上，
She speaks in an accent to introduce herself as Deb you taunt Deb for short Then we're gonna go through we're gonna meet Andy's character Nathaniel nutmeg and Aaron's character naughty Nellie nutmeg This is when Andy is very sad to learn that they are brother and sister. Phyllis is Beatrix Bourbon. Michael is successful playboy Caleb Crawdad. Angela, we know you are Voodoo Mama Juju.
她用一种口音说话，介绍自己是黛布，短命黛布（Deb you taunt Deb for short）。然后我们要接着往下看，我们要认识安迪的角色纳撒尼尔·萨姆杰格（Nathaniel Nutmeg）和艾琳的角色淘气内莉·萨姆杰格（Naughty Nellie Nutmeg）。此时安迪非常难过地得知他们俩是兄妹。菲利斯是贝atrix·波旁（Beatrix Bourbon）。迈克尔是成功的花花公子Caleb Crawdad。安吉拉，我们知道你是巫毒妈妈朱朱。
Well, Danny revealed that he wrote names for the whole cast, and Phil created cards for everybody. And we didn't get to hear all the names, but he told me what they were. Do you want to hear? I absolutely do. All right. Kevin is Dick Sealand. Okay.
丹尼透露说，他为整个剧组的所有人都写了名字，菲尔为每个人制作了卡片。我们没有听到所有的名字，但他告诉我它们是什么。你想听吗？我绝对想。好的。凯文是迪克·西兰（Dick Sealand）。好吧。
Oscar is Chad Anuga. Dwight is the butler Jeeves Julep. Jim is George Apeach. Ryan is Paul Meadow. Meredith is Connie Federate. And then he can't remember who got to sign these characters, but he did have to write two more prop cards and they were Barbecue and Carl Earned greens earned greens like it's a play on collard greens, but it's like Carl earned greens So those are all the names in here. Well, I did make note of all the props that went with each character. Voodoo Mama Juju. Angela had a voodoo head and a hat she had to wear. I did have a wardrobe fitting for that hat. Somewhere there were photos of me and multiple versions of that
奥斯卡是查德·阿努加（Chad Anuga）。德怀特是管家吉夫斯·朱勒普（Jeeves Julep）。吉姆是乔治·阿皮奇（George Apeach）。瑞安是保罗·米多（Paul Meadow）。梅雷迪思是康妮·费德雷特（Connie Federate）。然后他不记得是谁负责认领这些角色的了，但他确实还得写两张道具卡，它们是“巴贝que（Barbecue）”和“卡尔赚取蔬菜（Carl Earned greens）”，earned greens就像是对羽衣甘蓝（collard greens）的一个谐音梗，但听起来像“卡尔赚取了蔬菜（Carl earned greens）”。所以这里的名字就这些。好吧，我确实记录了与每个角色搭配的所有道具。巫毒妈妈朱朱。安吉拉有一个巫毒娃娃头和一顶她必须戴的帽子。那顶帽子我确实试过装。在某个地方有我和那顶帽子的多张不同版本的照片，
hat and that's the one the writers picked. Pam had lace gloves. Yes. Meredith had a long cigarette. Like a cigarette holder. Holder, yes. Kevin had a cigar. Phyllis had a feathery fan. Dwight had white butler gloves and it looked like a napkin over his arm. Erin had a lace garter and there was a deleted scene of her putting it on that didn't make it, but you see it ever so slightly at the end when she runs in the conference room.
那是编剧们挑选的一顶。潘有蕾丝手套。对。梅雷迪思有一根长烟。就像烟嘴一样。烟嘴，对。凯文有一支雪茄。菲利斯有一把羽毛扇。德怀特有白色管家手套，胳膊上还搭着一块看起来像餐巾的东西。艾琳有一条蕾丝吊袜带，有一个删减片段是她把它戴上的，但正片没放进去，不过你在最后她跑进会议室时能隐隐约约看到它一点点。
Andy had on men's sleeve garters, and I couldn't see what everyone else had, but those were the main ones that were visible. So Andy is going to try to teach Pam how to do a better accent because everyone's saying she just sounds like Forrest Gump. And he is able to do, like, a Florida panhandle accent, and then he gets into his description of a Savannah accent, where he says it's like, -"Malaya's just coming out of your mouth." It's so good.
安迪戴着男士袖箍，我看不清其他人有什么，但这些是主要能看见的道具。所以安迪要试着教潘怎么说好口音，因为每个人都说她听起来就像阿甘。他能模仿出一种佛罗里达狭长地带的口音，然后他开始描述萨凡纳口音，他说那种感觉就像——“马莱亚（Malaya）就从你嘴里冒出来一样。”太棒了。
Dani said they were originally planning for Andy to have a horrible accent, but on the day they realized that Ed was very good at these different accents and so they rewrote it. Well, he is from Georgia and he probably has a good ear for all the accents there. Interestingly enough, there was an Andy talking head in the shooting draft that did not make it.
丹尼说他们原本计划让安迪带着一种可怕的口音，但在当天他们意识到埃德非常擅长这些不同的口音，于是他们重写了剧本。好吧，他来自佐治亚州，他对那里的各种口音可能有着很好的耳力。有趣的是，拍摄初稿中有一个安迪的独白镜头最终没有被采用。
This is what it said. I went to dialect camp every summer from the age 7 to 18. Then I was a counselor for 10 years. Hmm. What? It was Andy's childhood. So we learned in the meeting that he spent a summer in Toulouse apprenticing for a fromager. Now we find out that he went to a dialect camp for years.
内容是这样的。我从7岁到18岁每年夏天都去方言夏令营。然后我当了10年辅导员。嗯。什么？这是安迪的童年。所以我们在会议里得知他在图卢兹度过了一个夏天，师从一位奶酪师傅学艺。现在我们发现他去过多年的方言夏令营。
Well, it's interesting, Angela, because we have wondered if deleted scenes count. If something doesn't make it into an episode, does it still count in that character's lore, in the story, whatnot? And sort of in the canon of the show, is it part of that? And we sort of said, no. No.
好吧，这很有趣，安吉拉，因为我们一直在想删减片段算不算数。如果有什么东西没有进入正片，它在这个角色的背景故事中、在剧情里或其他什么地方还算数吗？在剧集的正史（canon）中，它是其中的一部分吗？我们基本都说，不算。不算。
It's what aired. Yes. That is what would be the show Bible. Well, I found an old article on officeTally.com from 2007. Right when Google started, right, there was an interview with Greg Daniels. And he talked about this? Yes. What did he say? He said, quote, for the writers in our minds those scenes have happened. We wrote them, we shot them, and at the last minute I cut them in the editing room.
播出来的才算。是的。那才是剧本圣经（show Bible）。好吧，我在officeTally.com上找到了一篇2007年的老文章。就在谷歌刚兴起的时候，对吧，里面有一篇对格雷格·丹尼尔斯的采访。他谈到过这个？对。他说什么了？他说，引述如下：“对于编剧来说，在我们的脑海里，那些场景已经发生了。我们写了它们，我们拍了它们，而在最后一分钟，我在剪辑室里把它们剪掉了。”
But we're relying on them anyway for the mythology of the show. Wow, okay, so per Greg, if it made it in the shooting draft. If we shot it, then it's part of the mythology of the show. So that would mean that yes, Andy did spend a summer as a fromagee. He did do this weird accent camp. But here is the problem. SONIA DARA GILMORE What?
但为了剧集的背景神话（mythology），我们无论如何都还是会依赖它们。哇，好吧，所以根据格雷格的说法，如果它进入了拍摄初稿。如果我们拍了它，那它就是剧集背景神话的一部分。那这就意味着，没错，安迪确实作为一个奶酪师傅度过了一个夏天。他确实参加了这个奇怪的方言夏令营。但问题来了。SONIA DARA GILMORE 什么？
KATE BOWEN The exception that proves the rule would be Pam's painting. SONIA DARA GILMORE Because Pam's painting, they shot it being destroyed. It stayed off the wall for several episodes. It's still off the wall in this episode. In this episode, they're still just golfing inspiration. But it came back. So I don't know. I think it's still up for debate, Greg. Sorry, Greg.
KATE BOWEN 证明这条规则的例外就是潘的画。SONIA DARA GILMORE 因为潘的画，他们拍了它被毁坏的场景。它有好几集都没挂在墙上。在这一集里它依然没挂在墙上。在这一集里，他们甚至还在寻找灵感。但它又回来了。所以，我不知道。我觉得这还有待讨论，格雷格。对不起，格雷格。
We don't know. This interview does predate the destruction of the painting. So he's allowed to change his mind on that one. We don't know. This interview does predate the destruction of the painting. Okay. He's allowed to change his mind on that one. People are pretty impressed by Andy's accents. Kevin has a request. The sweetest chef. Andy's like, what province is he from?
我们不知道。这篇采访确实早于画作的毁坏。所以他有权改变对这个问题的看法。我们不知道。这篇采访确实早于画作的毁坏。好吧。他有权改变对这个问题的看法。大家对安迪的口音印象相当深刻。凯文有一个请求。最甜的大厨。安迪说，他是哪个省的？
And Kevin says, he lives on Sesame Street, dumbass. This got such a huge laugh at the table read, like people lost their minds. And when the final edit of the episode came and Greg saw it, it wasn't in. It got cut. Really? And Greg was like, where's Kevin's line about Sesame Street? He absolutely loved this line. And Greg fought really hard to have it put back in.
然后凯文说，他住在芝麻街，你个笨蛋。在围读剧本时，这个包袱引得全场哄堂大笑，大家简直笑疯了。而当这集进入最终剪辑、格雷格看到它时，这句台词没有了。被剪掉了。真的吗？格雷格当时就问，凯文关于芝麻街的台词呢？他非常喜欢这句台词。于是格雷格极力争取把它加了回来。
Well, I'll have you know, Stephanie M. from Salt Lake City, Utah, would like to point out that the sweetest chef does not live on Sesame Street. He's from The Muppet Show. Yes. Which makes the line even funnier. Yes. Well, why don't we take a break? Because when we come back, I need to point out a line that Phyllis could not say.
好吧，我要告诉你的是，来自犹他州盐湖城的斯蒂芬妮·M.想要指出，最甜的大厨不住在芝麻街。他是《布偶秀》（The Muppet Show）里的。是的。这让这句台词变得更搞笑了。对。那我们为什么不休息一下呢？因为等我们回来后，我得指出一句菲利斯说不出来的台词。
Ooh. And I have some things to say about Creed. We'll be back. We are back. And as you guys rewatch this episode with us, please go to the conference room scene where Phyllis has to say, I overheard you asking the butler whether pistol was kept.
噢。而且我对克里德（Creed）有些话要说。我们马上回来。我们回来了。当你们和我们一起重看这集时，请转到会议室的那个场景，菲利斯必须说：“我无意中听到你在问管家手枪放在哪里。”
Okay. Jenna, do you remember every time Phyllis got to the word pistol, she started to snicker and we all started to break? No. If you listen to it, she says pistol Pistole, because she can barely get through that word. We got tickled every single time. Oh my gosh. Now that you say it, I remember that.
好的。珍娜，你还记得菲利斯每次说到“手枪（pistol）”这个词时，她就开始窃笑，然后我们所有人都笑场了吗？不记得。如果你仔细听，她说的是“皮斯托（pistol）”“皮斯托尔（Pistole）”，因为她几乎没法把这个词完整说下来。我们每次都被逗得咯咯直笑。哦天哪。经你这么一说，我想起来了。
That would happen with Phyllis in general too. Yeah. It was everything. It was the Southern accent. She had to be doing the fan. And then when she said Pist pistol, it made me laugh. I remembered instantly how tickled we got. Well guys, Creed is gonna arrive to work.
这种事在菲利斯身上也经常发生。对。什么都能笑。就是南方口音。她还得一边扇扇子。然后当她说“皮斯托（pist pistol）”时，把我给逗笑了。我立刻就想起来我们当时笑得有多厉害。好吧，伙计们，克里德要来上班了。
He's late, he's sorry. He asks Michael what's going on, and Michael says, as Caleb crawdad, there's been a murder and you're a suspect. And Creed is like, oh, okay, great. Can I just have a... Let me get settled. I'll be right back. Yeah, I'll be right back. And he just high tails it right out of there. Now, some people
他迟到了，他很抱歉。他问迈克尔发生了什么事，迈克尔以Caleb Crawdad的身份说，发生了一起谋杀案，你是嫌疑人。克里德就说，哦，好吧，太棒了。我能不能先……让我安顿一下。我马上回来。对，我马上回来。然后他一溜烟直接跑出去了。现在，有些人
on some message boards think that this is an indication that Creed is the Scranton Strangler. Oh, sorry, that reaction was like a cartoon. Oh, I do declare. Yes, my goodness. However, I will say this. We see Creed leave. We see him jump into a car. I was like, oh, I think this is our first time seeing Creed's car.
在一些论坛上认为，这表明克里德就是斯克兰顿扼喉手（Scranton Strangler）。哦，抱歉，刚才那个反应就像个动画片。哦，我敢发誓。是的，天哪。不过，我要说的是。我们看到克里德离开。我们看到他跳进了一辆车里。当时我想，哦，我觉得这是我们第一次看到克里德的车。
I even asked Randy about it. He said that our transportation coordinator, Jesse Dutchover, rented that car from Cinema Vehicle Services. It is a picture car. That means cars that are rented out to productions to be in movies and TV. And that the rental facility was just a few blocks away. And we established this as Creed's car. And whenever we needed to see Creed in his car, this was the car they rented from this facility. Until he drove a Porsche years later. Correct. But in the future, when we see news footage of the police chasing who they think might be the Scranton Strangler, look at the car. Oh. It is not the car that Creed jumps into right here.
我还专门问了兰迪关于这辆车的事。他说我们的交通统筹杰西·达乔弗（Jesse Dutchover）是从“电影车辆服务公司（Cinema Vehicle Services）”租的那辆车。这是一辆道具车（picture car）。这意味着那些租给影视制作公司用于电影和电视剧的车。而且租车地点就在几个街区之外。我们将这定为克里德的车。每当我们需要看到克里德坐在他的车里时，这就是他们从那个租赁点租来的车。直到多年后他开上一辆保时捷。没错。但在未来，当我们看到警方追捕他们认为可能是斯克兰顿扼喉手的人的新闻画面时，看看那辆车。哦。那根本不是克里德在这里跳进去的那辆车。
Now, does Creed have many cars at his disposal after his work as the Scranton Strangler? Possibly yes, but I did just want to point out that there's a little bit of a car thing going on. I mean, Creed also, we have found out, lives under his desk and has a home in Canada. So anything can happen with Creed. I have some things to share as well. Greg said that Creed running to his car was actually a lot harder to shoot than it looks.
现在，克里德在作为斯克兰顿扼喉手作案之后，手头会有很多辆车吗？有可能有，但我只是想指出，这里面其实有点关于汽车的穿帮小细节。我是说，我们也发现过，克里德其实就住在他的办公桌底下，在加拿大还有一个家。所以克里德身上发生什么事都不奇怪。我也有一些事情要分享。格雷格说，克里德跑向他的车实际上比看起来要难拍得多。
Really? First of all, the timing of it. I mean, Creed had to really book it. He had to run to the car, he had to jump in, and then doing this back out and pull out move with a car as big as a Lincoln Town Car, which is what it is, was not easy. So this quick little moment actually took a little bit of planning. And lady, it's at this moment I realized that Creed the Character and me in real life have a little something in common. What's that?
真的吗？首先，时机把握。我是说，克里德真的得全速冲刺。他得跑向汽车，他得跳进去，然后用一辆像林肯城市车（Lincoln Town Car）那么大的车——这就是那辆车——来做一个倒车和驶出的动作，可一点也不容易。所以这个简短的小镜头其实花了不少筹划工夫。而且各位，正是在这个时刻，我意识到角色克里德和现实生活中的我有一点点共同点。什么共同点？
We have both driven Lincoln Town cars. Oh, you had a Lincoln Town car once? My grandmother's car was a green Lincoln Town car with a white top. And my grandmother's who taught me how to drive, because in the summers I would go stay with my grandparents for a visit. And when I was turning 16, she took me out
我们都开过林肯城市车。哦，你以前有一辆林肯城市车？我奶奶的车是一辆绿色的林肯城市车，配着白色的车顶。教我开车的人就是我奶奶，因为夏天我会去跟爷爷奶奶一起住，去探亲。当我快满16岁时，她带我开着她那辆
in her enormous Lincoln Town car. And that's was turning 16, she took me out in her enormous Lincoln Town car. And that's what I learned to drive a car in. Wow. You know, I learned how to drive in an enormous car as well. What was the enormous car? It was a 1978 Pontiac Catalina. Hey! That was a big long car. That was a big long car. My grandmother had pedal extenders, so that was good. So I wasn't right up on the steering wheel. You sort of had to learn in your grandmother's car.
硕大的林肯城市车出门了。我就是在那种车上学会开车的。哇。你知道吗，我也是在一辆硕大的车上学会开车的。什么硕大的车？那是一辆1978年的庞蒂亚克卡特琳娜（Pontiac Catalina）。嘿！那可是一辆又大又长的车。那是一辆又大又长的车。我奶奶有油门踏板延长器，所以挺好的。这样我就不用紧紧贴着方向盘了。你得在奶奶的车里学开车，是不是因为
Why? Because I'm short? Well, yeah, those pedal extenders really helped you out. They were very helpful. Apparently, I made my mom stressed out when she rode with me to teach me how to drive. So she gave it to your grandma. Yeah, my dad was like, I'm not getting in the car with her. So my grandmother said, I'll teach her to drive. And she did. Well, as your BFF who's ridden in many cars with you,
因为我个子矮？好吧，对，那些油门踏板延长器确实帮了你大忙。它们非常有用。显然，当我妈妈坐在我旁边教我开车时，我把她弄得很紧张。所以她把这任务交给你奶奶了。对，我爸爸当时说：“我可不坐她的车。”于是我奶奶说：“我来教她开车。”她确实教了。好吧，作为跟你一起坐过很多次车的最佳闺蜜（BFF），
you're a great driver. Thank you. Yeah, no pedal extenders anymore either. The seat goes all the way up. Although I wouldn't mind. Really? Yeah, cause then you're not so close to the steering wheel. Yeah.
你是个极好的司机。谢谢。对啦，现在也不用什么油门踏板延长器了。座椅可以调到最前面。虽然我不介意。真的吗？对，因为那样你就不会离方向盘那么近了。对。
So now we have a little romance in the kitchen. Andy and Erin, they're chatting, they're still doing their accents, but he asks her out on a date and she says yes. But then later in the conference room, other people start asking her out on a date and she's saying yes. And then Andy is like, oh wait, was she just in character in the kitchen? Or are we really going on a date? Did I ask out Naughty Nellie or did I ask out Erin?
现在厨房里有了一点浪漫气息。安迪和艾琳，他们在聊天，他们还在用他们那个口音说话，但安迪约她出去约会，她答应了。但后来在会议室里，其他人开始约她出去约会，而她也都答应了。然后安迪就想，等等，她刚才在厨房里只是在扮演角色吗？还是说我们真的要约会了？我约的是淘气内莉还是我约的是艾琳？
Well, in the conference room at 12 minutes 36 seconds, there is a really good shot of Kevin's character card where you can very plainly see that his name is Dixieland. And he's also has an extra prop in this scene. He's got a wad of money. Oh, yes. It's said in the script that he was one of the richest men in all of Savannah. Yeah. Well, so much so that he walks around carrying a wad of money. Oscar interrupts the game. He shares that he received an email from corporate instructing the accounting department to stop
好吧，在12分36秒的会议室里，有一个非常清楚的凯文的角色卡特写镜头，你可以非常清楚地看到他的名字叫迪克西兰（Dixieland）。而且在这个场景中他还有一个额外的道具。他有一大叠钱。哦，是的。剧本里说他是萨凡纳所有富翁中最富有的人之一。对。不仅如此，他到处走动时手里都拿着厚厚一叠钱。奥斯卡打断了游戏。他分享说他收到了一封来自总公司的电子邮件，指示会计部门停止
all payments to vendors. Wow, that's serious. Yeah. Well, Michael insists that Oscar give no more details unless he is speaking in character. He cannot use his Yankee accent, Michael says. So Oscar tries. To give important news about the company as a Southern character. We got mail. Mm-hmm.
对所有供应商的付款。哇，这很严重。对。好吧，迈克尔坚持要求奥斯卡除非用角色身份说话，否则不准透露更多细节。迈克尔说，他不准用他的北方佬口音。于是奥斯卡试着这么做了。以一个南方角色的身份传达关于公司的重要消息。我们收到信了。嗯哼。
Fan mail flurry on this one. Starting with Zach M. from Venice Center, New York. Does Oscar struggle with a southern accent in real life or was this just more of his brilliant acting? Zach, it was just brilliant acting. A hundred percent amazing acting job by Oscar. We did about six takes of this and Danny Chun spoke about this in an interview with OfficeTeli.com. He reminded me that at first Oscar was doing a really deep voice and it was the last take where he did the super high voice that we used in the show. Yeah. None of us were expecting it. We had gotten used to his low voice southern accent.
这一集迎来了粉丝来信狂潮。从纽约州威尼斯中心的扎克·M.开始。奥斯卡在现实生活中很难掌握南方口音，还是这只是他精湛演技的又一次展现？扎克，这纯粹是精湛的演技。奥斯卡百分之百惊人的精湛演技。我们大约拍了六条，丹尼·陈在接受OfficeTally.com采访时谈到了这一点。他提醒我，奥斯卡一开始用的是一种非常低沉的声音，直到最后一条他才用了我们在剧中采用的超高音。对。我们谁也没想到。我们都已经习惯了他低沉的南方口音。
That's right. We had a fan question from Jenny F. in Amarillo, Texas, and many others who wanted to know how did we keep a straight face during this scene. Oh, we did not. No. Especially not on that last take. Not the one you see. No. When he came in in that higher falsetto and he's talking about the greenback, we were on the floor. Even Steve broke and Steve never breaks. It made it onto the season six bloopers. I asked Cassie to pull it so we could hear it.
没错。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州阿马里洛的珍妮·F.以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道我们在拍这个场景时是怎么忍住不笑场的。哦，我们根本没忍住。没有。尤其是最后那条。不是你看到的那个。没有。当他用那种极高的假声走进来，谈论着绿背钞票（greenback）时，我们全笑瘫在地上了。甚至连史蒂夫都笑场了，而史蒂夫从不笑场。这个镜头被收录进了第六季的失误花絮里。我让卡茜把它调出来，这样我们就能听听了。
This here plantation is running low on greenbacks. Um, we ain't got no money to pay the people who sell us the seeds and dirt, manure. I can't do this, Michael. Basically. Thanks, go back. That was almost impossible. You can sort of hear Steve. I can recognize everybody's different laughs.
我们这个种植园的绿背钞票快用光了。嗯，我们没有钱付给那些卖给我们种子和泥土、肥料的人了。我演不下去了，迈克尔。基本上。谢谢，倒回去。那简直太不可能完成了。你隐隐能听到史蒂夫的声音。我能认出每个人的不同笑声。
I do too. I hear John. I hear definitely Brian and Steve. Oh yeah. Oh man, I rewatched the bloopers for that as well. And from the camera angle from our backs, my head is just bent over. Like I'm bent over. Oh, I have to say, whenever Oscar and Steve were paired together in a scene, just, I don't
我也能。我听到约翰的声音了。我绝对听到了布莱恩和史蒂夫的声音。哦，是的。天哪，我把那个花絮又重看了一遍。从我们背后的那个摄像机角度来看，我的头完全是耷拉着的。就像我弯着腰一样。哦，我必须得说，每当奥斯卡和史蒂夫在某个场景中被分到一组时，简直，我不知道
know what it was, those two, I think because they were the two that never broke, they got each other. They really did. Yeah. I wish, you know, there were more Oscar Michael moments. Like in re-watching, I'm like, gosh, man, I really wish that Oscar had to like do a sales call with Michael or something. Well, I know there's some good ones coming up. Oh, yeah.
是怎么回事，这俩人，我想因为他们是从来不笑场的两个人，他们特别合拍。他们确实如此。对啊。我希望，你知道的，能有更多奥斯卡和迈克尔的对手戏。就像重看的时候，我在想，天哪，我真的很希望奥斯卡能跟迈克尔一起去拜访客户推销（sales call）或者别的什么。嗯，我知道后面还有一些很棒的戏份。哦，对。
This news from Oscar really bumps people out and they go back to work. Also, the murderer is revealed on the tape. It was Phyllis. And she was really bummed because she felt like she was doing a good job. Yeah. Andy wants to figure out if he asked Erin out or if he asked out Naughty Nellie.
奥斯卡带来的这个消息让大家非常沮丧，于是他们回去继续工作了。此外，磁带里也揭晓了凶手是谁。是菲利斯。她其实挺郁闷的，因为她觉得自己表现得挺好。对。安迪想要弄清楚他到底是约了艾琳还是约了淘气内莉。
Right. So they have this great scene at front reception. I thought Ed and Ellie did such a great job just playing two people who like each other but are afraid to admit it. Mm-hmm. I agree. It ultimately ends up that neither of them admit that it was real when it was real for both of them. Yeah. So it's not gonna happen yet, but we are solidifying the information that they're into each other. Michael insists the game isn't over.
对。所以他们在前台有一个很棒的场景。我觉得埃德和埃丽把两个互相喜欢却又不敢承认的人演得太棒了。嗯哼。我同意。最终的结果是，明明对彼此都是动了真情的，但他们谁也没承认那是真的。对。所以这件事现在还没成，不过我们正在巩固他们对彼此有好感的信息。迈克尔坚称游戏还没结束。
He is now, I think he's in a full spiral. He will not break character. Danny talked about this and the challenge of writing for Michael when Michael isn't his true self. Oh. He said he had to write for Michael as Caleb Crawdad. And Greg compared this episode to grief counseling when Michael was unaware of what was motivating him. And the episode was playing out in his subconscious. And he said this episode is a variation of that
他现在，我觉得他彻底陷入精神崩溃了。他绝不出戏。丹尼谈到了这一点，以及当迈克尔不是真实的自己时，为迈克尔写剧本所面临的挑战。哦。他说他必须把迈克尔当作Caleb Crawdad来写。而格雷格把这一集比作悲伤辅导（grief counseling），当时迈克尔并未意识到是什么在驱使着他。而整集剧情在他的潜意识中上演。他说这一集是那种情况的变体，
where Michael is not sure what's motivating him, but he's locked into this character. That's really interesting. You know, Pam and Jim are going to have a talking head where they ask the question, has Michael snapped? Is he stuck in character? What's going on? I noticed something in this talking head.
即迈克尔不确定是什么在驱使他，但他完全沉浸在这个角色里。这真的很有趣。你知道，潘和吉姆将有一段独白，他们在其中提出疑问：迈克尔是不是精神错乱了？他是不是陷在角色里出不来了？到底怎么回事？我在这段独白里注意到了一件事。
What? I am wearing the same outfit that I wore in Double Date, which was last week's episode. It's exactly the same. I kind of noticed it earlier in the episode, but this talking head solidified it for me. Yeah, now that you say it, it's the exact same outfit. Exactly the same.
什么？我身上穿着和上周那一集《约会之夜》（Double Date）里一模一样的衣服。一模一样。我在这集前面就有点注意到了，但这段独白彻底向我证实了这一点。对，经你这么一说，确实是同一套衣服。一模一样。
It's that very kind of dark gray shirt with that lighter gray blazer. Yes, thank you. I was trying to get the words. The only thing that's different is that in Double Date, I'm wearing some little hoop earrings that I'm not wearing in this episode. I tried to figure out how did this happen?
就是那种非常深灰色的衬衫，配着一件浅灰色的小西装外套。是的，谢谢你。我刚才正想找这个词。唯一不同的地方在于，在《约会之夜》里，我戴着一些小耳环，而这一集里我没戴。我当时试图想弄明白，这是怎么发生的？
Why would Alicia put the same outfit in my trailer on Back to Back Weeks? Well, she didn't. I have a mom detective's moment. What? What'd you find out? I found out that we filmed these episodes in a different order than they aired. We originally filmed Double Date, then Koi Pond, then Murder.
为什么艾莉西亚（Alicia）会连续两周在我的化妆车里准备同一套衣服？好吧，她并没有。我有了一个“妈妈侦探”的高光时刻。什么？你发现了什么？我发现我们拍摄这些集数的顺序和它们播出的顺序不一样。我们最初拍摄的是《约会之夜》，然后是《锦鲤池》（Koi Pond），然后是《谋杀案》（Murder）。
Oh. So, there was a week in between. They aired as koi pond first, then double date, then murder. So I had gone up to the bigger belly bump, the Belly B, and it was only meant for these three episodes. And we had to tailor the clothes to the bump so I think Alicia was trying to get a little extra mileage out of my B bump wardrobe and she thought well as long as I throw an episode in between we won't notice that Pam has
哦。所以，中间隔了一周。播出的顺序是先播《锦鲤池》，然后是《约会之夜》，然后是《谋杀案》。所以当时我已经换上了更大的孕肚道具（Belly B），而且它本来就只打算用于这三集。我们不得不根据孕肚来剪裁衣服，所以我觉得艾莉西亚是想从我的孕肚服装预算里多榨取一点价值，她心想，嗯，只要中间隔播一集，我们就不会注意到潘
recycled this outfit but then they ended up airing back-to-back. So Pam's in the same clothes. Same clothes two weeks in a row. Good mom detective catch. Thank you. You know Dunder Mifflin closing is really gonna hit Pam and Jim hard. They both work there. They're married and both working at the same company. With a baby on the way. Yes I know and they're talking about that in Jim's office when Michael busts in and he's like, "'Come on, Deb, we need you, we need you.'" And Pam goes. At 17 minutes, two seconds, if you're curious what is splattered on the floor
循环穿了这套衣服，结果它们最后连着播了。所以潘连续两周穿着同一身衣服。连续两周穿同一身衣服。好一个妈妈侦探式的捉虫。谢谢。你知道邓德米夫林的倒闭真的会给潘和吉姆带来沉重打击。他们俩都在那儿上班。他们结了婚，又在同一家公司工作。还有一个即将出生的宝宝。是的，我知道，他们正在吉姆的办公室里谈论这个，这时迈克尔冲了进来，他说：“来吧，黛布，我们需要你，我们需要你。”然后潘就去了。在17分2秒时，如果你好奇梅雷迪思脑袋旁边
by Meredith's head, that's roast beef. It's from the little lunch platter that is there on the table. You can see all the roast beef has been placed on the floor. Jim has really lost his patience at this point and he demands to speak to Michael and Michael snaps back at him so hard. He's like, you shut up. Yeah. And we have one of those drama moments. Here's the thing. We've been wondering is Michael losing it? Has he gone crazy? And here's where you realize he's actually quite lucid.
溅在地上的是什么，那是烤牛肉。那是桌上那个小午餐拼盘里的。你可以看到所有的烤牛肉都被丢在了地上。吉姆此时已经完全失去了耐心，他要求跟迈克尔谈谈，而迈克尔严厉无比地顶撞了他。他说：“你闭嘴。”对。我们迎来了其中一个戏剧性时刻。事情是这样的。我们一直在纳闷：迈克尔是不是疯了？他是不是精神失常了？而正是在这里你意识到，其实他非常清醒。
And this is a choice. He is choosing to lose himself and help the office lose themselves in this game. Yep. It is a strategy. During all of this, David Wallace finally calls back. Jim takes the call. I thought Andy Buckley did such a great job, cuz you can just hear how distracted,
这是一个选择。他选择让自己迷失在游戏中，并帮助办公室里的其他人都在这个游戏中迷失自我。没错。这是一种策略。正当这一切发生时，大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）终于回电话了。吉姆接了电话。我觉得安迪·巴克利（Andy Buckley）演得太棒了，因为你能听出他当时有多分心，
slash worried, slash trying to put out a bunch of fires like his day, you know? Yeah, yeah, he was just sitting back in the annex at Kelly's desk making this phone call in real life, that's where he was. Well, everyone knows that Jim has just taken this call, and they're so anxious about what he's going to say. And there's no really anything good to say. And so Jim decides to join Michael. And he's like, turns out there's been another murder. And the look on Michael's face of like, oh, thank God he's with me. Well, I love their talking head. Michael has this line that rang so true to me.
或者说有多焦虑，或者说在极力处理一堆火烧眉毛的事，就像他那种日常一样，你知道吗？对，对，他当时其实就坐在 annex（附楼办公室）凯利的桌子后面打这通电话，现实生活中他就在那儿。好吧，大家都知道吉姆刚刚接了这通电话，他们非常焦虑他会说些什么。而且根本没有什么好消息可以说。于是吉姆决定加入迈克尔。他说：“情况有变，又发生了一起谋杀案。”迈克尔脸上露出了那种“哦，谢天谢地，他跟我是一伙的”的表情。好吧，我喜欢他们的独白。迈克尔有一句台词让我深以为然。
He says, today is the hardest I've worked in a long, long time. That was a pitch from Steve. Yeah, it's good. It's so good. I didn't know that he pitched that. Yeah. I mean, I also just thought of how hard Steve worked this week. Yeah.
他说：“今天是我好久好久以来工作最卖力的一天。”那是史蒂夫即兴提出的点子。对，太棒了。太棒了。我当时不知道那是他提出来的。对。我是说，我也想到了史蒂夫这周工作得有多卖力。对。
Like, that was a hard week. Yeah. Well, now Andy, Michael, and Dwight are in a three-way standoff with, like, finger guns. They're, like, pointed at each other. I guess Jim shares that Andy revealed himself to be a double agent, and then so was Dwight and as it turns out so was Michael.
就像，那是辛苦的一周。好吧，现在安迪、迈克尔和德怀特陷入了一场三方对峙，手里拿着类似手指枪的东西。他们正互相指着对方。我猜吉姆透露说安迪暴露了自己是个双重间谍，然后德怀特也是，结果证明迈克尔也是。
Also it's six o'clock and Jim would really like to go home. Yeah, but guess who he needs to get out of the conference room? Pam is part of this standoff. She is. Her finger guns are drawn as well. And she says to Jim, grab the keys, start the car. She's going to slowly back out of the conference room. And then the three-way standoff turns into a dramatic shootout. Everyone's writhing
另外已经六点钟了，吉姆真的很想回家。对，但你猜他需要把谁从会议室里带出去？潘也是这场对峙的一部分。没错。她的手指枪也举着呢。她对吉姆说：“拿上钥匙，发动汽车。”她要慢慢地退 出会议室。然后三方对峙变成了一场戏剧性的枪战。所有人都痛苦地扭动着
on the floor. We had a fan question from Caroline P. in Honolulu, Hawaii, for the tag at the end. How much of that scene was scripted and how much of it was just Steve, Ed, and Rain improvising and having fun with it? Well, I'll tell you what. In the script, it ends with Pam backing out of the conference room. It was supposed to just end on a standoff. And then on the day, they started doing the shootout, all shooting each other, and this is how it ended up being. Greg shared that when the guys fell on the ground
倒在地上。我们收到了来自夏威夷檀香山的卡罗琳·P.发来的粉丝提问，关于结尾的那个彩蛋。那个场景有多少是剧本写好的，又有多少是史蒂夫、埃德和雷恩即兴发挥、自得其乐的？好吧，我来告诉你。剧本里，剧情在潘退出了会议室那里就结束了。原本应该在对峙中直接剧终。然后在拍摄当天，他们开始玩起枪战，互相开枪，结果最后就变成这样了。格雷格分享说，当这几个人倒在地上
and were like convulsing and everything, that was just them, they were just having fun. He said it was like little kids getting to play. Yeah, it looked like it. It did. Well, at 20 minutes, 44 seconds, I wanted to point out one thing. The reveal of Pam is so great. And Greg shared what really made that happen was our camera operator, Matt Sohn.
开始抽搐和表演时，那完全是他们自己发挥的，他们只是在自娱自乐。他说那感觉就像是一群小孩子在玩耍。对，看起来确实如此。确实是。好吧，在20分44秒，我想指出一件事。潘的出场太惊艳了。格雷格分享说，真正促成这一幕的是我们的摄像师马特·索恩（Matt Sohn）。
His ability to whip around in a circle like that is what really captured the moment. Matt and Randall were so amazing. So whenever we can give a shout out to them. Way to go, Matt Sohn. We got another fan question from Patricia B. in Oklahoma who said, Jenna, how much did you enjoy that final scene when you were in the conference room doing your finger gun standoff? It was so fun. And it's like a very popular meme of me, you know, that says, I'm not going down for this, that line. It was so funny. I remember the direction from Greg was like,
他那种在原地转圈甩镜头的功力，才是真正捕捉到那个精彩瞬间的关键。马特和兰德尔太厉害了。所以有机会我们一定要向他们大声致敬。干得好，马特·索恩。我们收到了来自俄克拉荷马州的帕特丽夏·B.的另一个粉丝提问，她说：“珍娜，当你身处会议室进行手指枪对峙时，你有多享受那个最后的场景？”太有趣了。而且那成了我一个非常热门的表情包，你知道的，上面写着：“我才不会为这事认栽呢”，就是那句台词。太搞笑了。我记得来自格雷格的指导是：
you need to act like you are 100% invested in this. Like this is real in your mind. You have to get out. You have to get out and you're gonna get out safe. Yeah. I was like, all right, let's do it. And you got to be in a mini action movie. I did. On the office.
你得表现得好像你百分之百投入其中。就好像在你心里这一切都是真的。你必须逃出去。你必须逃出去，而且你要安全地逃出去。对。我就想：好吧，那我们上吧。然后你就演上了一部迷你动作片。我演了。在《办公室》里。
I did. Well, there you have it. That is murder. I wanna give a big thank you to Danny Chun for all of his details. He said you can find him at Danny Chun on Twitter. He's got a bunch of fun stuff coming up, but he said it's gonna be a while, not till the summer, but we'll post all about it when it's there.
我演了。好吧，事情就是这样。这就是《谋杀案》。我要非常感谢丹尼·陈提供所有的幕后细节。他说你可以在推特上通过@Danny Chun找到他。他有一堆有趣的新项目即将推出，但他说是还要等上一段时间，要到夏天才会出，不过等项目出来时我们会发文把一切都告诉大家的。
Well, of course, we always want to give a big shout out and lots of love to Randy Cordray, every week answering our questions. We love you, Randy. All right, you guys, well, we're taking next week off for spring break, but we'll be back the week after with Shareholder Meeting. Ooh, that's the RecycleOps. Oh yeah. And I am already trading emails with our costume designer Alicia Raycraft to get all the details on that RecycleOps costume transformation. I can't wait you guys have a great one.
当然，我们总是要向兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）表达我们极大的感谢和满满的爱意，他每周都回答我们的问题。我们爱你在，兰迪。好了，各位，接下来我们要为春假停播一周，但两周后我们会带着《股东大会》（Shareholder Meeting）回归。哦，就是那个“循环行动（RecycleOps）”。哦，对。而且我已经在跟我们的服装设计师艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫特发邮件沟通了，以获取关于那个“循环行动”服装大变身的全部细节。我等不及了，祝大家过得愉快。
Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fischer. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Keefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
拜拜。感谢收听《办公室闺蜜》。《办公室闺蜜》由Earwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们节目的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡茜·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室闺蜜》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Stitcher Premium上注册即可享受一个月的免费试用，使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。